Könnte ich im Hintergrund bitte mal das übliche Gerumpel haben und so klatsch, ja so aus einer Art, weil auch im neuen Jahr wollen wir doch von alten Gewohnheiten nicht lassen. Herzlich willkommen zum ersten Chaosradio im Jahre 2006. Das ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Das Chaosradio gibt es immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat auf allen Frequenzen von Fritz im Rahmen des Blue Moons. Nur nicht im Dezember, da ist nämlich der Chaos Communication Congress und darum fällt da das Chaosradio aus. Herzlich willkommen zu Chaosradio 1 oder 9, das Thema der heutigen Sendung. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz im Studio Frank-Rosengard und ein echter Doktor. Wir haben uns gedacht, wir holen mal einen Arzt. Das ist der Christoph Bruch. Der ist Mitglied im Bundesvorstand der Humanistischen Union. Für alle, die nicht wissen, was die Humanistische Union ist, was macht ihr da so?
Die Humanistische Union ist die älteste Bürgerrechtsorganisation Deutschland. Wir kümmern uns um alles.
Seit wann gibt es euch?
Seit 1962 gibt es uns. Und wir kümmern uns um alles, was die Bürgerrechte betrifft. Das heißt, wir kümmern uns darum, wenn Demonstrationen sind, werden wir das vielleicht beobachten, wie die Polizeieinteste laufen. Wenn neue Sicherheitsgesetze verabschiedet werden, dann testen wir die aus. Neben Stellungen bei den Anhörungen. Wir kümmern uns auch ums Informationsfeuerheitsgesetz, machender Lobbying, solche Sachen.
Also ein Experte im Studio, das Dröhnen, was ihr im Hintergrund hört, kommt übrigens von der Klimaanlage, die extra für die Rundfunkstudios, die hier gebaut wurden, abgeschirmt wurde.
Ja, bevor wir zum Thema kommen, ich hab ein paar Sachen, die wir ansagen wollen, die wir loswerden wollen. Es gibt ein paar Termine, das sind so viele, ich hoffe, ich vergesse nicht alles. Zum einen gibt es in einem RW-Tempel in Friedrichshain eine Netlabel-Party am Samstag. Es ist insofern interessant, es ist nicht eine ganz gewöhnliche Party, sondern eine Party, wo nur freie Musik gespielt wird. Das heißt also, normalerweise zahlt man ja an die GEMA und es ist halt diese ganze Musikindustrie, die dahinter hängt. Und mit dieser Party am Samstag ist es wahrscheinlich eher elektronische Musik. Es hat damit auf sich, dass es einfach wirklich freie Musik ist. Das heißt auch Musik, die ihr einfach runterladen könnt, die ihr, wenn sie euch gefallen hat, ganz legal zu Hause auf euren Computer holen könnt, ohne dafür zu bezahlen.
Dem Christoph sein Computer macht Geräusche.
Der macht Musik. Dann gibt es noch einen Hinweis zum einen, wie wir uns hören können.
Din-dil-din-dil-din.
Ja, super.
Wir haben ja auch einen Podcast. Das ist Sport, also ich mag es eigentlich ja nicht. Also eigentlich sind wir ja sowieso ein ganz alter Podcast. Und es gibt es ja schon ewig, weil wir auch unsere Mitschnitte im Netz haben. Aber jetzt machen wir das auch so richtig, dass man es auch ganz einfach klicken kann. Zum Beispiel mit iTunes, wo es dann auch so Hitparaden gibt, wo wir dann auch gerne dabei sind. Aber wir wollen jetzt auch noch auf Platz eins sein. Wir wollen in dem Zusammenhang auch noch auf den Chaosradio Express hinweisen, der also zusätzlich mit einer gewissen Regelmäßigkeit jetzt auch zum Chaosradio entsteht. Und ich möchte darauf hinweisen, dass es morgen im New Thinking in der Tucholski Straße auch einen Einführungsvortrag zu Podcasts gibt. Das heißt, wenn ihr selber mal Podcasts machen wollt, dann seid ihr da genau richtig aufgehoben.
Ich hab noch was rausgeholt, wir haben ja kurz eben bei Paul schon zugehört, von einer Viertelstunde oder 20 Minuten haben wir kurz gespielt, dass Edmund Stoiber schon im Jahre 2002 den Transrapid so toll fand, dass er sich eineinhalb Minuten lang um Kopf und Kragen geredet hat, obwohl er ein Manuskript hatte, von dem er dann aber abgewichen ist.
Wo auch nur zwei Sätze eigentlich standen, ne?
Ich weiß gar nicht, das war auf jeden Fall sehr kurz, ja, das war ein sehr kurzes Manuskript. Und es gibt jemanden, der hört auf den Namen oder hat ihn sich selbst gegeben, Databoy78, über den Namen reden wir dann nochmal gesondert. Databoy78, und der hat sich diesen Stoiber redende Mitschnitt vorgenommen und Musik draus genommen.
Am Hauptbahnhof in München starten sie ihren Flug.
Also ich meine, die Rede von Stoiber war ja wirklich großartig. Es gab Anfragen, ganz viele von euch wollten unbedingt... Schaut doch einfach mal, geht mal auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Da ist ein Link zu der Mitmachseite bei Wikipedia, die wir haben, wo wir so ein ganzes Material und Links für die Sendung sammeln. Und wir kommen jetzt gerade nicht dazu, aber es ist von euch da draußen. Irgendjemand weiß bestimmt, wo diese Stoiber L3...
Das kann ich ja kurz sagen. Das liegt im Webblog von Mario Sixtus.
Genau. www.http.com Genau, und wenn jemand von euch da draußen so nett wäre, das gerade auf der Wikipedia-Seite noch mit einzuflegen, dann haben alle was davon.
Jörg Chaosradio 109, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, ist das Thema der heutigen Sendung.
Dieser Begriff ist ein bisschen unhandlich und ziemlich lang und sagt eigentlich aus, dass es jetzt ein neues Gesetz gibt, was eigentlich gar nicht so neu ist. In Berlin und in ein paar anderen Bundesländern gibt es schon seit ein paar Jahren, nur es weiß niemand davon. Es gibt jetzt die Möglichkeit, dass ihr, ihr Bürger, zu den Behörden gehen könnt und sagen, ich würde jetzt gerne eine Akte sehen. Und zwar eine bestimmte Akte, wo ihr schon immer mal wissen wolltet, was da drin steht. Es kann über euch sein, es können Verwaltungsakten sein. Und es gibt jetzt sozusagen das Recht, ihr habt jetzt das Recht, diese Akten einzusehen, ihr könnt die anfordern. Und was es genau damit auf sich hat, darüber wollen wir heute reden. Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Klingt eigentlich ziemlich gut. Ist schon fast zu schön um Bart zu sein.
Klingt nicht gut, das klingt deutsch.
Das klingt deutsch, aber die Idee ist grundsätzlich gut. Im Englischen heißt es übrigens Freedom of Information Act, ist da ein bisschen bekannter geworden und zwar in Zusammenhang mit Fotos von mit Sergen von US Amerikanern. Das ist so dieses Foto ist da in meinem Zusammenhang mit diesem Freedom of Information Act. Ich glaube das kann Christoph besser.
Also das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, wie Frank schon sehr richtig gesagt hat, bezieht seinen Namen aus der direkten Übersetzung des amerikanischen Begriffes Freedom of Information Act. Deswegen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und die Spezialisten unter euch, die schon mal ins Grundgesetz geguckt haben, die kennen vielleicht...
Ich meine jetzt nicht den Hintergrund des Gesetzes, Entschuldigung, sondern die Geschichte mit den Sergen.
Ach die Geschichte mit den Sergen. Die Geschichte mit den Sergen ist ganz einfach, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in den USA, der Freedom of Information Act, wurde dort von einem Journalisten, Kik Russ, genutzt, um bei der Navy, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, Bilder zu beantragen von den Sergen der GIs, die im Irak umgekommen sind.
Die aus gutem Grund auch unter Verschluss gehalten werden dann natürlich auch von den GIs.
Dann die wurden ja rausgegeben. Das zeigt sozusagen, dass dieses Gesetz durchaus seine Kraft entfalten kann. Und die hat er dann veröffentlicht auf seiner Website. Und es hat am nächsten Tag direkt die New York Times aufgegriffen und damit auf der ersten Seite aufgemacht.
Das ist so ein bisschen zur Vorgeschichte, wo der Begriff herkommt, für das Information Act, deswegen ist es ja auch so ein bisschen unhandlich geraten. Die ganze Sache ist ja nicht ganz so einfach, das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Dann wären jetzt plötzlich Behörden gezwungen, die halt bisher einfach gesagt, wir machen ja unsere Sachen, wir sind Beamte und Bürger, warum geht es hier eigentlich? Wir beantworten ja nicht irgendwelche Fragen. Wir sind ja hier nicht irgendwie eine Auskunftei oder wir machen hier unseren Job. So und jetzt kriegen die Bürger plötzlich das Recht an die Hand, einfach zur Behörde zu gehen, sagen, ich werde jetzt die und die Akte sehen. So und ich darf das. Ich habe jetzt das Recht dazu und jetzt geht mir die mal raus. Wie einfach war es denn, so ein Gesetz in Deutschland durchzusetzen, Christoph?
Das war furchtbar schwer. Der Prozess geht im Prinzip schon, wenn man das zurückverfolgt, bis in die 60er, 70er Jahre zurück. Seitdem gibt es diese Forderung in Deutschland, besonders angeheizt durch den Erfolg, der in den USA erzielt wurde. Da wurde das Gesetz 66 verabschiedet. Und dann bildet es sich über lange Zeit, wenn man so will, eine Art Community innerhalb der Parteien zunächst mal. Und mit der Zeit wurde diese Forderung so fest in den, wie soll ich das sagen, in das Spektrum der Linken eingegliedert, dass es eben irgendwann über die Grünen in den Bundestag gekommen ist. Da ist das 87 das erste Mal als Gesetzentwurf eingebracht worden in den Bundestag. Und bei den Koalitionsverhandlungen für unsere letzte Regierung wurde beschlossen, solch ein Gesetz zu verabschieden.
Du sagst, bei der Linken hat sich diese Community gebildet. Das heißt, CDU und CSU haben blockiert, die wollten das nicht. FDP, wie sah es mit denen aus?
Die FDP unterstützt das Gesetz. Und bei CDU und CSU herrscht einfach ein anderes Demokratieverständnis vor. Die sind der Meinung, dass die Öffentlichkeit, die benötigt wird, über die Parlamente hergestellt wird.
Das klingt aber dann doch eher, als hätten die was zu verbergen. Also ich meine, das ist doch wirklich ein so schwaches Argument.
Ich glaube, verbergen ist da der falsche Begriff. Das würde ich so nicht sagen. Es geht einfach darum, ob man meint, man lebt am besten mit einem repräsentativen System, wo professionelle oder semi-professionelle Menschen dafür zuständig sind, den Staat sozusagen zu führen. Oder man hat ein Demokratieverständnis, bei dem man meint, es kommt auf das Engagement von jeder Einzelne an und zweiteres ruft nach einem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Denn ohne Information keine Partizipation.
Zumal die Vierte Macht, also die Medien ja nicht mehr in dem Maße funktionieren, also zumindest habe ich oft das Gefühl, dass sie nicht mehr in dem Maße funktionieren, wie sie eigentlich funktionieren sollten, nämlich dann auch tatsächlich die zu kontrollieren, die den Staat führen. Also dafür sagen wir ja häufig genug.
Es gibt genug Untersuchungen über die Interessen und Interessenzusammenhänge zwischen Politikern und Journalisten, immer wieder ein großes Problem. Deswegen ist es natürlich sehr wichtig, dass auch unabhängig Leute recherchieren können. Und Deutschland ist übrigens eine Ausnahme mit seinen Landespressegesetzten, die es den Journalisten ein besonderes Informationsrecht gibt. Das ist in anderen Staaten nicht so geregelt.
Das heißt, es ging uns schon gut, aber wir haben es nicht in dem Maße benutzt, wie es vielleicht manchmal notwendig gewesen wäre?
Na ja, ich habe das eigentlich jetzt eher kritisch gemeint. Also in anderen Staaten sozusagen haben alle Bürger gegenüber dem Staat ein gleich gutes bzw. gleich schlechtes Informationsrecht. Und bei uns über die Landespressegesetze haben Journalisten ein Auskunftsrecht. Und dann kann man sich natürlich fragen, wieso soll eine Berufsgruppe mehr wissen dürfen als der Rest der Bevölkerung?
Wir werden im Laufe der Sendung noch ein bisschen mehr darüber reden. Von euch, euch Zuhörern, wollen wir gerne wissen, wenn ihr jetzt die Möglichkeit habt, bei den Behörden irgendwelche Dokumente, irgendwelche Akten anzufragen, was wolltet ihr eigentlich schon immer mal sehen?
Was wolltet ihr eigentlich schon immer mal sehen? 0331 70 97 110. Um das nochmal zu verdeutlichen. Also alles. Ich kann da hingehen und habe grundsätzlich erst mal das Recht, alles zu sehen, was da an Akten irgendwo lagert.
Wenn es nicht einen guten Grund gibt, dass was dagegen spricht.
Aha.
Wir gehen davon aus, dass es uns gestattet ist und euch damit auch gestattet ist, jedes Dokument einzusehen, das in einer Behörde in irgendeinem Akten Deckel klebt. Erst mal alles. Also erst mal ohne gute Gründe es euch nicht zu zeigen. Die guten Gründe können wir euch dann hier aufzählen, falls ihr sagt, ich würde gerne die Steuererklärung von Frank Rosengardt sehen. Die liegt ja schließlich auch irgendwo bei einer Behörde rum. Ruft mal an und erzählt, was ihr gerne sehen würdet. 0331 70 97 110. Chaosradio 109 auf Fritz. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist das Thema der Sendung heute ein relativ sperriger Name.
Selbstverteidigung für Bürger.
Selbstverteidigung für Bürger, sehr schön. Es ist eine sehr angenehme Sache, denn es ist uns gestattet bzw. wie nennt man das? Es wird uns gestattet. Nein, es wird im Grunde werden die Behörden gezwungen.
Wir nehmen ein Bürgerrecht wahr.
Wir nehmen ein Bürgerrecht wahr und dieses Bürgerrecht ist tatsächlich Einblick zu nehmen in den zunächst mal sämtliche Akten, die bei irgendeiner Behörde rumliegen. Geht mal davon aus, dass ihr immer schon mal eine Akte sehen wolltet, welche auch immer. Vielleicht beim Bauamt, weil die schon wieder so eine komische Verkehrsberuhigung bauen, die da gar nichts zu suchen hat oder oder oder. Und überlegt euch, welches Dokument ihr gerne mal sehen würdet, wenn ihr denn jetzt dieses Dokument sehen dürft und das dürft ihr. Und das Dokument, das prangert ihr an unter 0331779110, bitte.
Dass wir ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz für den Bund haben, also für die Bundesbehörden, ist jetzt eine relativ neue Sache. Am 1.1. ist es ein Kraftgetretenes Gesetz. Wir haben aber in ein paar Bundesländern schon seit ein paar Jahren diese Informationsfreiheitsgesetze, zum Beispiel auch in Berlin. Nur, also ich werde jetzt mal den Behörden nicht böse Absicht unterstellen, aber es wird natürlich nicht großartig breitgetreten.
Es ist ja nicht der Job der Behörden, das breitgetreten ist unser Job, der Job der Medien, oder? Ich meine, wer soll uns breit treten?
Ich meine, im Prinzip könnten die Behörden ja eigentlich auch alle Informationen, die sie haben, online stellen. Also das ist ja eigentlich sozusagen das Endziel oder das Idealziel, was ich mir eigentlich wünsche. Also warum muss ich erst umständlich nachfragen, wenn es das Internet gibt? Ich kann einfach alle Dokumente abfragen. Der Bundestag macht es ja schon teilweise, das klappt ganz gut. Im Abgeordnetenhaus in Berlin ist es nicht so zufriedenstellend. Ja, also ich habe es auch schon mal probiert, eine Auskunft nach den Informationsfreiheitsgesetzchen in Berlin zu bekommen. Das war dann gar nicht notwendig, es war bei der BVG, es ging um einen Geschäftsbericht. Wobei es auch fraglich ist, ob die BVG da überhaupt runterfällt, weil es ja eigentlich keine Behörde ist, aber eine Anstalt öffentlichen Rechts. Das ist ein bisschen nicht ganz so einfach. Letztendlich haben die das aber auch ohne irgendwelchen bürokratischen Umweg mir die einfach geschickt.
Es ist aber auch wirklich mal eine interessante Frage, Christoph. Eine Anstalt des öffentlichen Rechts, wie zum Beispiel der Rundfunk Berlin Brandenburg, kann ich den auf Grundlage des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes jetzt zwingen, seine Zahlen mal offen zu legen? Dass man einfach mal sagt, er erzählt mir mal, wie ihr die Gebühren verwendet, die er kassiert?
Das ist eine knifflige Frage. Also ich weiß, dass wir bei den Bundesinformationsfreiheitsgesetze haben wir eine Ausnahmeregelung drin für die Rundfunkanstalten, dass die nichts rausgeben müssen.
Interessant. Die wissen auch warum.
Ich bin jetzt unsicher, wie das bei den Landes... Das wird dann juristisch kompliziert, dann müsste ich jetzt in die einzelnen Landesgesetze reingucken. Ich glaube allerdings, in Berlin ist es nicht ausgenommen. Ich würde sagen, und auch in Brandenburg ist meines Wissens nicht ausgenommen, ich würde sagen, hier in Berlin und in Brandenburg können wir zugreifen.
Wäre ein Versuch wert. Das ist eine Kritik, der ich natürlich oft ausgesetzt bin, denn ich arbeite beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Sie haben immer wieder gesagt, ihr kassiert hier Geld und ihr macht nur Mist. Und ich sagte immer, nein, machen wir nicht. Wir machen ja gute Sachen damit. Und dann erklärt mir mal, wie viel Prozent von der Kohle, die ihr einnehmt, fließt denn eigentlich in Toilettensanierung und in Radio machen und so was. Wäre ein Versuch wert.
Aber wenn jetzt die ganzen Bürger wirklich von dem Recht Gebrauch machen, kann es nicht passieren, dass die Behörden irgendwann lahmengelegt werden? Das war ja, glaube ich, auch eine der großen Sorgen dabei, dass man halt gesagt hat, als es zu dem Gesetz kam, um Gottes willen, haben die ja noch mehr Arbeit, die sind eh schon überlastet und wie sollen die das denn alles machen? Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, die Möglichkeit auf diese Akteneinsicht, gibt es ja schon in den Bundesländern. Gibt es da Erfahrungswerte, wird von dem Recht überhaupt Gebrauch gemacht? Wie viel Arbeit fällt da wirklich bei den Behörden an?
Also das Gesetz gibt es in vier Bundesländern. Es gibt es in Brandenburg, das war das 1.98. 1999 kam Berlin, 2000 Schleswig-Holstein und 2001 Nordrhein-Westfalen. In diesen vier Ländern haben wir Erfahrungen mit diesem Gesetz und die sind durchweg positiv. Die Ämter sind nicht überlastet, das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Und rund 90 Prozent der Anfragen werden auch ohne Probleme voll gewährt. Insofern kann man sagen, voller Erfolg. Das sagen auch alle, die daran beteiligt sind. Auch die CDU übrigens, die auch schon eigene Vorschläge für das Gesetz inzwischen eingebracht hat. Nämlich in NRW damals beim Gesetzgebungsprozess und aktuell arbeitet sie im Saarland daran.
90 Prozent der Anfragen werden beantwortet. Welche Anfragen hättet ihr? 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritz-Hortlein. Und ihr seid eingeladen, mal zu erzählen, welche Papiere ihr denn gerne bei der Behörde einsehen würdet, jetzt wo ihr sie einsehen dürft. 0331 70 97 110 hat Volker angerufen. Hallo Volker.
Und zwar würd ich gern mal wissen, bei welchen Betrieben überall so Gammelfleisch gefunden worden ist.
Ach, das ist nicht öffentlich, diese Information bisher?
Nein, ich hab da vor ein oder zwei Monaten, als der ganze Skandal da so groß in den Medien war, mal ne Marktsendung oder so gesehen. Und da wurden auch bei verschiedenen Ämtern Anfragen gemacht, wo es denn jetzt genau gefunden wurde. Und da wurde eben keine Auskunft gegeben.
Mit welcher Begründung?
Bitte?
Mit welcher Begründung haben die das gesagt?
Es gab auch keine Begründung. Also es gab überhaupt keine Stellungnahme, nur halt, dass sie keine Auskunft geben. Und da frag ich mich doch, ob das nicht irgendwas damit zu tun hat, jetzt ob Auskunft gegeben wird oder nicht, falls da irgendwelche wirtschaftlichen Interesse im Hintergrund stehen oder andere Interessen. Und ob man dann nicht mehr so großzügig damit umgeht.
Müssen die es begründen?
Ja, also das ist das Besondere an den Informationsfreiheitsgesetzen. Wenn ein Bürger Einsicht in Akten nehmen möchte, dann sagt das Gesetz grundsätzlich, die Türen stehen offen, die Akten müssen rausgegeben werden. Nur, und jetzt kommt das große Aber, wenn eine Ausnahmeregelung greift, dann müssen die Akten nicht herausgegeben werden. Und eine dieser Ausnahmeregelungen ist der Schutz von Betriebs- und Geschäftsgeheimnissen. So, und man kann natürlich trefflich darüber streiten, ob die Information darüber, dass ein Unternehmen gammeliges Fleisch verkauft hat, ein Betriebs- und Geschäftsgeheimnis ist.
Oder zum Beispiel, ich hab mal einen Bericht gelesen über die mafiösen Strukturen bei der Fahrbahnmarkierung. Also es gibt wohl eine Fahrbahnmarkierungsmafia, die den Markt komplett unter sich aufgeteilt haben und auch die, wer auch immer das ist, Tiefbauämter fest im Griff halten oder sowas. Da war ich echt mal hinreichend erschüttert. Dann hätte er wahrscheinlich auch Geschäftsgeheimnisse. Könnt ihr mal versuchen, also mal die Fahrbahnmarkierung, also alle Akten zur Fahrbahnmarkierung mal rausgeben zu lassen.
Ich möchte eine interessante Geschichte erzählen in dem Zusammenhang. Also vielleicht ist ja für euch die Eichämter ein Begriff. Also die, die nachgucken, dass die Maße eingehalten werden, die beispielsweise gucken, ob im Supermarkt in den Nudelpackungen, auf denen 500 Gramm steht, auch tatsächlich 500 Gramm Nudelpackungen drin sind.
Blasenfrei zapfen.
Genau. Und diese Eichämter, die veröffentlichen auch Jahresberichte. Da brauchen wir also gar keinen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz für. Und vor drei Jahren ist der Bundesverbraucherzentrale aufgefallen. Aha, die Eichämter haben vermehrt Fertigverpackungen gefunden. Da sind aber gar nicht 500 Gramm Nudeln drin, sondern von mir aus nur 450. Daraufhin haben die gesagt, na dann gucken wir doch mal, ob wir Ross und Reiter zusammenbringen können. Und haben in den vier Bundesländern mit Landesinformationsfreiheitsgesetzen sich an die Eichämter gewandt und gesagt, nun sagt uns doch mal, welche Firmen sind das denn, die ihre Packungen nicht richtig befüllen? Und in allen vier Fällen ist dieses Begehren abgelehnt worden. Mit der Begründung, die Information darüber, dass dieses Unternehmen unterfülle, werde ein Betriebs- und Geschäftsgeheimnis verletzt, wenn das freigegeben würde. Und davon haben die geklagt in Schleswig-Holstein. Und im Amtsgericht und im Verwaltungsgericht ist diese Klage jetzt in zwei Instanzen gescheitert. Also sie haben bisher die Informationen nicht rausbekommen und gehen jetzt vor das Oberverwaltungsgericht.
Das heißt, diese Firma darf mich bescheißen. Und wird dafür vom Staat auch noch gedeckt.
Das ist total pervers. Ich kann es wirklich nicht anders sagen. Das ist völlig unverständlich. Aber das gibt es noch. Aber ich möchte auch sagen, das ist sicher nicht repräsentativ für das Denken aller Menschen in der Verwaltung.
Aber wir haben jetzt hier ein Radio, also Aufruf an alle. Geht doch einfach mal in den Supermarkt, kauft mal Nudeln oder nehmt euch mal Nudelpackungen, nehmt euch eine Waage und wiegt mal nach. Dann kann man das ja empirisch vielleicht in irgendeinem Webblog oder auf der Mitmachseite im Chaosradio im Nudelblog veröffentlichen. Also dann kommen wir dem einfach zuvor, indem wir es als Privatleute empirisch versuchen nachzuvollziehen. Und ich hoffe mal, dass es dann Einnudeln sind, die esse ich sowieso nicht so gerne. Volker, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Volker würde, wenn er könnte, sich mal von den Behörden sagen lassen, wo denn überall Gammelfleisch gefunden wurde bei welchen Betrieben, damit man dann vielleicht hinterher weiß, welche Betriebe da zu meiden sind. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist das Thema im heutigen Chaosradio 109 auf Fritz. Und ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110 und uns zu erzählen, welche behördlichen Dokumente ihr denn gerne mal euch angucken würdet, jetzt wo ihr sie euch angucken dürft.
Fritz präsentiert die Bloodhound Gang. Sonntag, 19. Februar, ab 20 Uhr in der Columbia Halle Berlin. Die Bloodhound Gang, live und im Radio.
Äh, eine nach halb elf.
Nachrichten.
Mit Matthias, äh, Kerkov.
In der BND-Affäre wird es vorerst keinen parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss geben. FDP und Linkspartei haben es nicht geschafft, einen entsprechenden Gruppenantrag durchzubringen. Bei der Partei erreicht nur 125 Stimmen, 154 wären aber nötig gewesen. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel will den Bürokratieabbau voranbringen. In ihrer Eröffnungsrede auf dem Weltwirtschaftsforum im schweizerischen Davos sagte sie, die Vereinfachung der Verwaltung werde ein Hauptthema der deutschen EU-Präsidentschaft 2007 sein. Merkel bekräftigte ihr Ziel, Deutschland in den nächsten zehn Jahren wieder in die Spitzengruppe in Europa zu führen. Die Bundesregierung hat weiterhin kein Lebenszeichen von den beiden im Irak entführten deutschen Ingenieuren. Wie Bundesaußenminister Steinmeier mitteilte, gibt es bislang auch keinen Kontakt zu den Entführern. Inzwischen steht das sächsische Unternehmen zunehmend in der Kritik, weil es seine beiden Mitarbeiter in den Irak reisen ließ. Und zum Sport. Im Viertelfinale des DFB-Pokals gab es am Abend folgende Ergebnisse. Aminia Bielefeld kickers Offenbach 4 zu 2 im FB erschießen. 1860 München Eintracht Frankfurt 1 zu 3. Und soeben schlug St. Pauli Werder Bremen mit 3 zu 1. Die Basketballer von Alba Berlin haben mit ihrem 15. Sieg im 17. Spiel ihre Spitzenposition in der Bundesliga verteidigt. Sie besiegten Energie Braunschweig mit 98 zu 79. In dieser Nacht wieder wechselnd bewölkt, Temperaturen minus 5 bis minus 10 Grad. Es wird also deutlich wärmer als die Nächte zuvor. Und morgen wird es in Heiter bis Wolkig auch deutlich wärmer. Es bleibt trocken bei minus 5 bis minus 2 Grad. Bei zwei Meldungen haben wir A12 Berliner Ring Richtung Frankfurt oder zwischen Mölrose und im Grenzübergang Frankfurt gibt es zehn Kilometer stockenden Verkehr, Staugefahr durch LKW. A24 Berliner Ring Richtung Pritzweig zwischen Kremen und Färberlin. Nach einem Unfall ist der Standstreifen und zum Teil die rechte Spur blockiert.
Vielen Dank Matthias Kerkov, drei Minuten nach halb elf.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5? Dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder...
Chaosradio 109 und das Thema ist das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, ein Gesetz, das es den Bürgern gestattet, zunächst einmal jegliches Dokument, jegliche Aktenvermerk und was es da sonst so gibt, bei den Behörden einzusehen, es sei denn wichtige Gründe sprechen dagegen. Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110 und mal zu erzählen, was ihr euch denn gerne mal angucken würdet, welche Dokumente, welche Akten würdet ihr gerne veröffentlicht haben, beziehungsweise zumindest für euch mal zur Einsicht dargeboten bekommen. 0331 70 97 110, eben haben wir schon gehört, das Gammelfleisch, wo das gefunden wurde, wäre vielleicht mal eine gute Sache, um das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz auszutesten. Du hast seltsame Musik mitgebracht, Frank. Hab ich, haste, haste gut gemacht. Und hier ist das Chaosradio 109 auf Fritz. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist unser Thema. Ihr seid weiterhin eingeladen anzurufen. Unter 0331 70 97 110 mal zu erzählen. Welche behördliche Information ihr denn offengelegt haben wollen würdet, beziehungsweise offengelegt haben wollt, denn ihr habt mittlerweile ein Recht auf die Offenlegung dieser Informationen. Das heißt, kann ich doch jetzt auch hingehen und sagen, Bundesnachrichtendienst, ihr sorgt dafür, dass hier die CIA Bundesbürger entführen darf, gib mal die Akten dazu raus.
Das ist natürlich eine Frage, die viele gerne stellen würden und das hat sich auch der BND, das haben sich die Geheimdienste auch schon vorher überlegt und deswegen haben die sich ausbedungen, dass sie ausgenommen sind. Das gibt dann eine sogenannte Bereichsausnahme innerhalb des Bundesinformationsfreiheitsgesetzes und diese Bereichsausnahme gilt nur für die Geheimdienste. Also die Informationen, die bei denen stehen, sind leider, leider nicht zugänglich.
Was ist mit den BKA, LKA, solche Sachen? Also das sind ja sicherlich auch endlos interessante Akten in den Kellern des Staatsschutzes und weiß der Geier was zu finden.
Diese Akten sind, sag ich jetzt mal, theoretisch zugänglich. Theoretisch deswegen, weil das muss einfach jetzt ausgetestet werden. Also wir haben eine ganze Reihe von Ausnahmbestimmungen. Also Informationen, deren Herausgabe die Sicherheit der Bundesrepublik Deutschland beeinträchtigen würde, sollen nicht herausgegeben werden. Das muss man dann eben auch austesten.
Sagt Christoph Bruch von der humanistischen Union, die kennen sich aus, testet ihr das denn jetzt alles aus, die humanistische Union, oder wartet ihr darauf, dass stinknormale Bürger das machen?
Ja, da gibt es ja noch einen Haken. Nämlich der Haken ist nicht allein die Ausnahmebestimmung, sondern der ganze kostet Geld. Ach, das heißt, wenn ich eine Information bekomme, können dafür Gebühren bis zu 500 Euro erhoben werden. Und wir sind hier ein armer kleiner Verein. Das heißt, wir müssen uns das sehr genau überlegen, ob wir so einen Antrag stellen. Also einen oder zwei können wir stellen, aber wir können nicht beliebig viele stellen. Und ich bin gerade am recherchieren. Es gibt ja viel Stress um das Gesundheitssystem in Deutschland. Und da gibt es eine Stelle, die sammelt Daten darüber, wie gut in den Krankenhäusern gearbeitet wird. Und diese Stelle ist von sich selbst der Meinung, dass sie nicht von diesem Gesetz betroffen ist. Das versuche ich zu klären. Und wenn ich das gleich hinkriege, dass sie betroffen sind, dann würde ich versuchen, rauszukriegen, wo die schlechtesten Operationen gemacht werden.
Ja, und da lasse ich auch nochmal ein Hunderter springen, um euch beizuspringen, wenn die da 500 Euro für haben wollen. Also das würde ich auch ganz gerne noch rausgefunden bekommen. Mit was für einer Begründung lehnen die das ab?
Das weiß ich noch nicht, denn ich habe die letzte Woche angeschrieben und habe ihnen eine Frist gesetzt bis Ende dieser Woche, um mir mitzuteilen, wieso sie meinen, dass sie nicht betroffen sind.
Das war nicht schlecht. Anheben und die Luft einfach anhalten. Der wollte doch gerade was sagen.
Ich hab's doch genau gehört.
Schön angetäuscht. Ja, wenn ich jetzt tatsächlich einen Auskunftsbegehren hab, also ich hab so diffusen Ideen, es gibt da so eine Akte über zum Beispiel Luftverschmutzungsdaten und ich weiß aber gar nicht genau, wen muss ich da jetzt eigentlich fragen? Gibt's sowas wie eine zentrale Anlaufstelle? Oder wie muss ich da eigentlich vorgehen, wen spreche ich da an, wenn ich jetzt so eine Akte haben will?
Also im Prinzip ist es ganz einfach. Man geht zu der öffentliche Stelle, bei der man die Information vermutet. Und diese öffentliche Stelle ist verpflichtet, einen zu beraten, den Antragsteller. Das heißt, wenn die Information nicht dort ist, dann sind sie gehalten. Zu sagen, nein, nein, lieber Antragsteller, dann geben wir zu unseren Kollegen da und da. Und dort kannst du diese Information beantragen.
Da bin ich dann aber auch in der Lage, also ich meine, wenn ich eine hinreichende Menge Menschen finde, die mitmachen, kann ich schon Behörden tageweise lahmlegen damit, oder? Ständig zu falschen Behörden rennen und sagen, ich hätte gern die Ausgut zu Thema XY?
Die Frage ist nicht, ob die Behörden dich lahmlegen können, indem sie dich irgendwie ein paar Wochen lang oder monatelang im Kreis rumschicken. Wie ist das? Ist das theoretisch möglich? Oder sind die denn verpflichtet auch nach bestem Gewissen sozusagen, also wahrscheinlich wissen sie es noch nicht, also wahrscheinlich machen sie es nicht mal mit Absicht, dass sie dich im Kreis schicken. Aber was ist jetzt meine Strategie, um möglichst zielgerichtet an die Information zu kommen?
Natürlich ist es gut zu wissen, wo die Information, die man sucht, liegt. Und der Gesetzgeber hat auch mitgedacht und hat den Behörden aufgegeben, Aktienverzeichnisse möglichst elektronisch zu veröffentlichen, damit ich das rauskriegen kann. Aber eben bin ich auch in der Lage, beraten zu werden. Aber es gibt natürlich auch negative Beispiele, auch hier aus Berlin. Da hat eine Person herauskriegen wollen, wie stark die Asbestbelastung in einem Gebäude einer Berliner Universität ist. Welche Universität tut hier nichts zur Sache? Und hat sich deswegen auf Grundlage des Berliner Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes an die entsprechende Universitätsverwaltung gewandt. Diese Universitätsverwaltung hat sie ewig und drei Tage vertröstet. Und dann ging es von der Universitätsverwaltung an den Senat und von den Senat wieder an eine andere Stelle. Und das ganze Spielchen hat sich zweieinhalb Jahre hingezogen.
Da kannst du schon dran merken, dass was nicht stimmt, oder?
Ja, in diesem Fall ist es eine klassische Situation. Da ist durch die Ämter gemauert worden. Und dann gibt es aber eine Anlaufstelle. Und zwar ist der Berliner bzw. Brandenburger Datenschutzbeauftragte auch durch die Informationsfreiheitsgesetze zum Informationsfreiheitsbeauftragten gemacht worden. Also in Berlin Dr. Dix oder in Brandenburg Frau Hartke, Informations- bzw. Datenschutzbeauftragte. Die helfen dann weiter, die unterhalten sich mit den entsprechenden Stellen. Und wenn alles nichts hilft, muss man klagen.
Und das macht aber nicht mehr der Datenschutzbeauftragte für einen. Also der ist unbewaffnet sozusagen.
Der ist unbewaffnet, das ist ganz wichtig. Der kann zwar eine Meinung äußern, aber auch wenn er der Meinung ist, dass die Information herausgegeben werden müsste, hat er keine Weisungsbefugnis gegenüber der Behörde.
Eigentlich schade. 0331 70 97 110, seid ihr eingeladen anzurufen, um zu erzählen, welche Informationen, also welche Dokumente ihr gerne von der Regierung, der Bundesregierung, eurer Landesregierung, vielleicht auch nur von der Kommune haben wollt, oder von irgendetwas anderem, was da so behördlich im Gange ist.
Von der Schulbehörde vielleicht?
Von der Schulbehörde vielleicht, das stimmt ja, da gibt es ja auch, mann. Ja stimmt, allein weil ich als Schüler gerne alles gewusst hätte, was da so läuft und warum denn bestimmte Menschen bestimmte Unterrichte geben und andere wiederum nicht. 0331 70 97 110 hat der Jan aus Sachsen angerufen, grüß dich. Was willst du gerne mal sehen?
Ich bin ein bisschen gespaltener Meinung darüber. Ach. Das ist mein Problem. Ich habe also ein kleines Unternehmen. Ja, so mit sechs Beschäftigten.
Was macht das Unternehmen? Also was stellst du her?
Wir sind spezialisiert auf Granit-Verkleidung, Naturschleim-Verkleidung und so weiter. Ich habe das Problem, wenn ich Information haben will über Kundschaft, ja, komme ich nicht, das ist ganz schwer. Das heißt, ich habe nur zwei Möglichkeiten. Ich habe eine Möglichkeit, einmal über eine Kriseform nachzufragen, über einen Schuh fahren noch.
Also meinst du jetzt, ob die Kunden zahlungsfähig sind? Richtig.
Und auch diese Informationen, die sind erst mal finanziell, mit einer finanziellen Leistung verbunden. Ich muss bezahlen für Informationen. Und das sehe ich da nicht mehr ein. Ich sehe nicht ein, dass ein Journalist hingeht, kriegt Informationen, kostet ihn keinen Pfennig.
Ich muss für jede Anfrage... Warte mal, wenn ich als Journalist zur Kreditreform gehe und sage, ich möchte wissen, ob Frank Rosengard zahlungsfähig ist, dann muss ich genauso zahlen wie jeder andere auch.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also die Frage ist für mich gut nachvollziehbar. Das Problem dabei ist, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz gibt mir die Möglichkeit, auf Informationen zuzugreifen, die bei den Behörden, die von dem Gesetz abgedeckt werden, vorliegen. Die SCUFA ist keine Behörde, die hat mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz nichts zu tun. Das ist ein privates Unternehmen.
Das ist richtig, aber wenn ich nachfragen will, zum Beispiel ich arbeite als Superunternehmer für, was weiß ich, Firma X. Und es ist bekannt, man kennt ja auch viele, man hört da übrigens rum zum Beispiel, da das ist schon, was weiß ich, zweimal übernommen, zweimal Insolvent und so weiter. Man fragt jetzt zum Beispiel öffentlichen Aufträgen nach, man bekommt keinerlei Information.
Von wem jetzt? Von der Schufa?
Wenn jetzt vom Auftrag, wenn zum Beispiel eine Gemeinde oder eine Kommune oder was weiß ich, oder das Land oder irgendeine Institution einen Auftrag vergeben, einen öffentlichen Auftrag. Und ich sage, okay, ich bin ja eine kleine Firma, meist arbeite ich als Superunternehmer. Wie sieht es aus, ist die Firma nichts, null.
Moment, aber jetzt nicht die Behörde, die Auftraggebende Behörde, sondern eine andere Firma, oder?
Nein, die Auftraggebende Behörde.
Ob eine Behörde pleite ist oder?
Wenn ich zum Beispiel, ich habe einen Auftrag, geht ein halbes Jahr, dreiviertel Jahr lang. Es gibt Erzahlungsschwierigkeiten.
Keine Behörde aus?
Nein, bei meinem Auftraggeber.
Ja, aber das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, Entschuldigung, Jan, das Thema unserer Sendung ist das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Und das bezieht sich ausschließlich auf Behörden, nicht auf irgendwelche Auftraggeber, auf irgendwelche Geschäftsverhältnisse.
Die Behörde ist für mich die Gemeinde. Sie haben insofern Recht mit Ihren Fragen. Natürlich können der Gemeinde in diesem Fall Informationen darüber vorlegen, wie die Bonität eines bestimmten Auftragsnehmers, wie es darum bestellt ist. Jetzt ist die Frage, ob die Gemeinde diese Information rausgeben darf oder nicht. Ich bin der Meinung, dass Sie da wahrscheinlich fast zu Ihrem Gewerbe auf Granit speisen werden. Denn das Problem ist, dass die erstens sagen, wenn die Gemeinde rausgibt eine negative Information, dann ist das geschäftsschädigend. Ich erinnere an Herrn Breuer, der gerade vorgestern verurteilt worden ist. Das wäre also eine problematische Sache. Das zweite ist, eine der Ausnahmetatbestände in den Informationsfreiheitsgesetzen ist der Datenschutz. Das heißt, Sie wollen sozusagen in doppelter Weise da rein. Sie wollen sozusagen den Datenschutz austesten und Sie wollen ein Betriebs- und Geschäftsgeheimnis, also das ist kein Betriebs- und Geschäftsgeheimnis, aber das ist eine sehr problematische Sache, sich negativ über die Bonität eines Unternehmens zu äußern.
Darf ich kurz unterbrechen? Ich will ein kurzes Beispiel nennen. Ein Auftraggeber, der einen öffentlichen Auftrag bekommt, muss nachweisen, dass er seine SV-Beiträge abführt und so weiter und so fort. Bevor der Auftrag kommt, ist das mal in die Behörde. Die Behörde prüft das. Es stellt sich heraus, dass die Firma gar nicht mehr insolvent ist, auf Deutsch gesagt, nichts abführt und so weiter. Und diese müsste eigentlich darüber jeder, der an dem... Weil ich muss ja auch sämtliche Informationen abgeben. Verstehen Sie mich? Ich muss alles, ich muss mich offenbaren mit allem. Ich muss jeden Monat nachweisen, dass ich meine Sachen abführe, aber nicht mal der Firma, für die ich arbeite, sondern dem Auftraggeber. Aber der Auftraggeber sagt mir nicht, dass die schon seit einem Vierteljahr nichts mehr abgeführt haben.
Sie haben hier ein ganz, ganz großes, kitzliches Problem angegriffen. Es geht nämlich um die Frage, wie weit die Privatsphäre geschützt wird. Darum geht es im Kern bei der Sache, die Sie ansprechen. Und die Informationsfreiheitsgesetze, die setzen auf der Datenschutzgesetzgebung, die wir seit zig Jahren haben, auf. Und im Prinzip sagen Sie, nein, wir müssen eine veränderte Datenschutzgesetzgebung haben. Wir müssen den Schutz der Privatsphäre dann einschränken, wenn es notwendig ist, beispielsweise um sicherzustellen, dass Leute nicht betrügerisch Aufträge herausgeben, die sie hinterher nicht bezahlen können.
Das ist aber eine Gratwanderung, oder?
Ja, ja, das ist eine problematische Sache. Aber ich muss sagen, dass das natürlich insofern kompliziert ist, als Sie ja in diesem Fall von einer Behörde unter Umständen eine Beurteilung erwarten. Und Informationsfreiheitsgesetze zeichnen sich dadurch aus, dass die Behörde nur Informationen, die bereits vorliegen, rausgibt. Da gehört übrigens auch dazu, dass nicht geprüft wird, ob die Informationen stimmen. Wenn Sie eine Akte beantragen und die Akte rausgegeben wird und die Behörde weiß, dass in einer Akte speziell in dem Teil, die sie interessiert, ein Fehler ist, muss sie selbstverständlich darauf aufmerksam machen. Aber sie muss nicht prüfen, ob das, was in der Akte steht, stimmt. Und Sie wollen ja eine Bonitätsauskunft haben. Da kommt es auch drauf an, wie sieht es denn aktuell aus? Der war ja vielleicht vom halben Jahr pleite, aber ist er jetzt noch pleite? Also das ist eine Sache, da kommen Sie mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz nicht weiter.
Das heißt, wir müssen auch keine neuen Akten anlegen oder keine neuen Erkenntnisse sammeln, um Ihnen eine Auskunft zu geben.
Nein, müssen die nicht.
Aber sind Sie nicht der Meinung, dass da was geändert werden müsste? Es kann nicht sein, dass die Kleinen, auf Deutsch gesagt, im Dunkeln gelassen werden und alle anderen wissen Bescheid.
Wieso wissen alle anderen Bescheid?
Ja, es ist so, wenn ein Auftraggeber von mir Bescheid weiß, dass dort etwas nicht stimmt. Und der Auftraggeber prüft jedes Subunternehmen. Auf Herz und Nieren fragen sie mich nicht, ob das gigantisch ist. Und man wird im Regen stehen gelassen.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Die Kritik verstehe ich gerade tatsächlich nicht.
Die Kritik ist, dass jeder öffentliche Auftrag, das ist ja Gesetz in Deutschland, muss jeder, der den Auftrag hat, nachweisen, dass er seine Abgaben tätigt. Ich schwarze mal kurz jetzt. Wenn dieser Auftraggeber, dieser Behörde bekannt ist, dass das nicht passiert, seit längerem Zeitraum, und weiß aber, dass viele andere Kleine damit arbeiten.
Ich würde mal sagen, es gibt coole Beispiele. Die Behörde ist aber doch nur in einen Vertrag eingegangen mit dem Hauptauftragsnehmer. Und die Subunternehmer darunter, die stehen doch nur in Beziehung zu dem Hauptauftragsnehmer, oder nicht?
Das ist richtig rechtlich gesehen, ja. Aber wenn die Behörde die Auftraggeber ist, und sie kommen als Verfall hinterher, sie überprüft nach Nieren.
Das heißt, die Behörde überprüft auch jeden einzelnen Subunternehmer?
Auch die werden. Ich muss jeden Monat abführen. Ich muss jeden Monat mir zum Beispiel bestätigen lassen, von der Krankenkasse, wo die Leute versichert sind zum Beispiel, dass ich die Beiträge abführe und so weiter und so fort.
Und das müssen Sie weiterleiten an die Behörde, an den Auftraggeber?
Genau so ist es.
Also eine interessante Frage wäre, ob ich von der Behörde eine Akte bekommen kann, ob denn auch wirklich ordnungsgemäß kontrolliert wurde. Also gar nicht mal mit Nennung der Firmen, sondern eher generell.
Genau, nicht mit Nennung der Firmen.
Sondern ob ich eine Liste bekommen kann, wie viel von den Firmen eben nicht darunter sind. Und dann möglicherweise auch wieder quasi da sagen kann, dass ein unfaire Wettbewerb gelaufen ist. Das wäre ja vorstellbar.
Was ich eigentlich ein bisschen seltsam finde, ist, also wir haben den Auftraggeber, also die Behörde. Die Behörde gibt, er teilt den Auftrag an Firma A. Firma A beschäftigt Subunternehmer B und C. Jetzt verpflichtet die Behörde, die Subunternehmer B und C, Beiträge abzuführen. Prüft aber gleichzeitig nicht, dass Unternehmen A, also der Hauptauftragnehmer, seine Beiträge abfügt.
Das ist hier gang und gäbe in Deutschland. Das beste Beispiel, das ist ja auch bei Großbaustellen gewesen, ob das im Zentralstaat Leipzig war, oder jetzt in Stuttgart Neuemesse. Das sind ja aber Riesendinger, sag ich jetzt mal. Da hat die Behörde geschlafen.
Aber solche Sachen kriegt man ja dann sehr wohl.
Mir geht es darum, was man vom Kleinen verlangt, kann ich auch von der Behörde verlangen, dass die ihren Aufgaben nachkommt.
Darf ich sie nochmal unterbrechen? Ich halte ihr Anliegen für sehr gut nachvollziehbar. Ich glaube allerdings, dass die Stoßrichtungen, wenn ich das politisch betrachte, dann bräuchten wir sozusagen eine Initiative, sozusagen eine Stärkung des Mittelstandsinitiative, die sagt, wir müssen, ob das nun über Gesetzgebung funktionieren muss oder nicht, das kann ich aus dem Stehkreis nicht beurteilen. Wir müssen Rahmenbedingungen schaffen, die es kleinen Unternehmen ermöglichen, bevor sie Aufträge übernehmen, festzustellen, ob die Auftraggeber überhaupt solvent sind. Ich kann ihr Anliegen sehr gut nachvollziehen, das ist auch ganz wichtig, denn sie sind ja die Jobbringer, diese kleinen Unternehmen. Insofern bin ich da voll auf ihrer Seite, aber das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist sozusagen nicht der direkte Weg dorthin. Das muss eine eigene Initiative sein. Aber sie haben uns natürlich mit dem Hinweis hier auf eine ganz wichtige Sache gebracht, das ist nämlich im Zusammenhang mit Informationsfreiheit, Datenschutz. Das ist ein ganz großes Thema.
Darf ich zum Abschluss noch was sagen? Was die gerade gesagt haben, das haben uns viele Regierungen versprochen vorher.
Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist unser Thema. Habt ihr eben gehört, ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen, zu sagen, in welche Informationen ihr denn gerne, welche Informationen ihr denn gerne befreien würdet. Kann man auch mal so sagen. Also bei Behörden liegen sehr viele Informationen rum, sehr viele Akten im Keller. In diese Akten dürft ihr jetzt reingucken. In welche würdet ihr, wenn ihr die Wahl habt, wir zahlen das dann eben an der Stelle mal, in welche Akte würdet ihr gerne reingucken? 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Name Jens. Super Sache, Touchscreen. Name Jens.
Ich wollte dich fragen, wie sich das verhält, wenn man jetzt tatsächlich von der Behörde die Auskunft gekriegt hat und meinetwegen irgendwie die Akten in der Hand hält. Kann man die dann zum Beispiel einscannen und einfach veröffentlichen, damit alle anderen dann auch Zugriff haben? Oder darf man das dann nicht?
Das darf man.
Denn dann müssen ja die Leute nicht doppelt und dreifach gucken. Dann kann man ja auch eine Wiki oder sowas weiter einrichten, wo die alle dann nachgucken können.
Das kann ich nur nur sehr, sehr befürworten. Und auch der Gesetzgeber hat schon so im Grundsatz soweit gedacht. Er hat nämlich in das Gesetz reingeschrieben, nach Möglichkeit und Informationen, von denen erwartet wird, dass sie nachgefragt werden, veröffentlicht werden, damit da keine Anträge gestellt werden müssen.
Welches veröffentlichst du dann, Jens?
Also ich hab mir noch nicht groß Gedanken darüber gemacht, was ich jetzt von ihren Wörtern jetzt groß wissen wollte.
Echt, hast du dich noch niemals, hätt ich nicht in die Neuge gepackt.
Also ich hab natürlich während ich hier am Telefon hing drüber nachgedacht, aber mir ist ja jetzt auf den Schlag nichts eingefallen. Aber es gibt ja noch genügend andere Hörer, die sich äußern können.
Ja, dann wollen wir mal hoffen, dass sie anrufen.
Glaubst du denn, dass damit ein bisschen das Desinteresse an der Politik vielleicht geringer werden könnte, dass die Leute dadurch aktiv werden und sich versuchen, da ein bisschen mehr einzubringen?
Ja, weiß ich nicht genau, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn Leute irgendwie mit Problemen konfrontiert sind, dann eine bessere Möglichkeit haben, dann mal die Behörden zu kontrollieren, was sie tun und ob sie jetzt, ja, also das halt.
Also glaubst du schon, dass das ein wirksames Mittel ist zur Selbstverteidigung? Auch in Anführungszeichen für Bürger. Das heißt also, was in der Hand zu haben oder einfach auch mal aktiv werden zu können?
Ja, also ich erinnere mich da dunkel an irgendwie so ein Bericht, der mal, also wo es dann um eine Firma ging, die irgendwas da im Osten von Brandenburg machen wollte. Und da haben dann die Behörden irgendwie gemauert, weil da die Leute, die drin saßen, irgendwas persönlich gegen den hatten oder keine Ahnung. Und dieses Gesetz hat das dann irgendwie, weil er dann auch geklagt hat, irgendwie ermöglicht, das dann halt zu beweisen, dass die tatsächlich nur gemauert haben und ihm dann irgendwie nur Steine im Weg gelegt haben. Also das ist dann sicherlich eine gute... Also ich weiß nicht genaueres drüber, aber irgendwie so war das. Und das ist dann sicherlich schon ganz praktisch und ganz gut, wenn man die Behörden dann halt darauf verklagen kann, spätestens, dass dann mal die Unterlagen rausrücken.
Ich lass erst mal sagen, wie das hier heißt. Chaosradio 109, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist das Thema der heutigen Sendung. Im Studio Frank vom CCC und Christoph von der humanistischen Union. Die kümmern sich um solche Sachen wie Informationsfreiheitsgesetz C, von denen es ja mehrere gibt, nämlich auf Bundesebene und auf Landesebene haben wir eben gelernt. Es gibt ja immer mal wieder Vorfälle, dass irgendwelche internen Ermittlungen stattfinden und Polizisten nur versetzt werden, obwohl sie Dreck am Stecken haben. Man hört ja die abenteuerlichsten Geschichten, nennen wir es mal so. Bin ich in der Lage, in diese Akten Einsicht zu nehmen?
Also ich kann hier, wenn solche Fragen kommen, natürlich nicht immer in jedem Fall sagen, das wird rausgegeben werden und das wird nicht rausgegeben werden. Man kann natürlich diese Informationen beantragen und dann wird man sehen, ob die rausgegeben wird. Also ich vermute, wenn es sich wie hier um eine Sache handelt, die in der Personalakte steht, dass dann die Ausnahme für Datenschutz greift und die eher nicht rausgegeben wird. Das muss man, aber das kommt wirklich sehr genau auf den einzelnen Fall an. Also ich bringe mal ein Beispiel auch aus Berlin aus dem vergangenen Jahr. Da wollte jemand Details wissen über einen Polizeieinsatz. Da war eine Razzia in einer Kneipe. Und er hat diesen Antrag gestellt. Und ganz wichtig, wenn man auf Grundlage des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes einen Antrag stellt, muss dieser Antrag nicht begründet werden. Man sagt, ich will und nicht wieso. Die Polizei fand das merkwürdig, wollte das eigentlich wissen, wieso. Und wollte auch erst die Informationen nicht rausgeben. Und dann hat sich der Informationsfreiheitsbeauftragte eingeschaltet. Und die Information wurde herausgegeben. Also man sieht auch, die Polizei kann transparent werden.
Mache ich mich eigentlich verdächtig, wenn ich bei der Polizei oder bei irgendwelchen Behörden was anfrage, dass ich irgendwie irgendwas Böses im Schilde führe?
Ja sicher, es ist die Polizei.
Nee, also in meinem Ernst, also auch bei anderen Behörden kriege ich denn da irgendwie einen speziellen Aktenvermerk. Das wäre...
Kannst dann aber auch hinterher fragen, ob du einen gekriegt hast.
Dauerbeschäftigung?
Aber ich denke mal, wenn du zur Polizei gehst und sagst, ich würde ganz gerne Informationen über die letzte Razzia in Weiß der Geier was haben, da werden die sich schon denken, warum will er das haben.
Also ich habe ein sehr lustiges Beispiel gelesen, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, dass ich glaube ein heftigener Strafanstalt wollte gern vom Bauamt die Baupläne der Strafanstalt haben.
Also wenn er irgendwo in Brandenburg gesessen hat, dann ist das sowieso nicht so schlimm, da brechen sie eh alle nasslang aus, da kriegen sie auch ohne Baupläne auf die Reihe. 0331 70 97 110, die Nummer der Fritz-Hotline, das hier ist der Blumen, das Chaosradio 109. Möglicherweise habt ihr die eine oder andere Frage oder Anmerkung zum Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Und uns würde immer noch interessieren, welchen Informationen ihr denn gerne die Freiheit geben würdet jetzt, wo ihr es dürft. Also in welche Akten bei welcher Behörde würdet ihr gerne mal reingucken. 0331 70 97 110, Name Kai.
Einen schönen guten Abend. Ich hab mal eine Frage. Ich komme aus dem OSL-Kreis.
Du hast dein Radio an. Mach das mal bitte aus.
Oh ja, einen Moment bitte.
Das gilt übrigens auch für alle anderen, die dann hier anrufen und mitreden wollen. Radio muss aus sein. Alles klar Kai.
Gut, meine Frage ist, kann ich bei der Arbeitsagentur für Arbeit umweichen?
Du hast dein Radio doch immer noch an. Du hast dein Radio doch immer noch an oder sitzt du auf dem Klo?
Ne, ich sitz da auf Arbeit, meine Halle schallt so ein bisschen. Und ob ich dort meine persönliche Akte über meinen Hartz-IV-Vermerk anfordern kann. Mir wurde das jetzt immer wieder verweigert auf so und so ein paar Grafen.
Was ist ein Hartz-IV-Vermerk?
Also ihre Akte können sie auf jeden Fall bekommen. Und zwar nicht auf Grundlage des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes, sondern auf Grundlage des Datenschutzgesetzes. Und zwar schon seit den 80er Jahren. Es gibt auf Grundlage eines Urteils des Bundesverfassungsgerichts die sogenannte informationelle Selbstbestimmung. Also das Recht von Ihnen, über alle Informationen bei der Verwaltung zu erfahren, die Sie persönlich betreffen. Dazu geben die Datenschutzbeauftragten in allen Ländern auch sogenannte Datencheckhefte heraus. Und wenn Sie Informationen bei einer Arbeitsagentur oder einem Jobcenter vermuten und diese Informationen haben wollen und nicht bekommen, dann gehen Sie zum Datenschutzbeauftragten, der wird Sie da unterstützen. Ein klassischer Fall, Sie sind da 100% im Recht.
Kai, was ist ein Hartz-IV-Vermerk?
Man bekommt halt eine Akte, wenn man arbeiten geht, auf einen Eurojob mäßig, bekommt man den Vermerk in seiner Akte und das ist dann halt ein kleiner Aktenvermerk, dass man auch Hartz-IV-Unterstützen bekommt während seiner Arbeit. Das ist nur der sogenannte Hartz-IV-Vermerk.
Alles klar. Du hattest noch eine Frage, ne?
Dann bedanke ich mich noch und wünsche noch einen schönen Abend.
Jo, Dankeschön. Du hast Gutei. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz im Chaos Radio auf Fritz.
Ich bin schon mal da.
Ich bin.
Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da. Es ist keine einfache Frage, wie wir eben festgestellt haben, so aus dem Stand mal eben so, welche Informationen wir gerne sehen. Falls euch was Gutes einfällt, 0331 70 97 110 und falls ihr natürlich auch Fragen habt zum Informationsfreies Gesetz, seid ihr ebenso eingeladen hier anzurufen, an der Fritzertlein und eure Fragen zu stellen. Im Studio Frank vom CCT und Christoph von der Humanistischen Union. Und der kennt sich bestens aus mit dem Informationsfreies Gesetz, weil die Humanistische Union ist eine Nichtregierungsorganisation, die sich um Bürgerrechte kümmert. Und wie war es die älteste Nichtregierungsorganisation in Deutschland?
Die älteste Nichtregierungsorganisation. Und ich hätte auch noch eine weitere Frage an unsere Hörer. Und zwar würde mich interessieren, als Beispiel, in Berlin hat ein Journalist Einsicht beantragt in den Terminkalender des Regierenden Bürgermeisters. Jetzt würde ich da gerne mal wissen von euch, findet ihr, dass diese Information rausgegeben werden sollte? Oder findet ihr, nein, der Terminkalender des Regierenden Bürgermeisters, ich rede von den offiziellen Terminen, nicht von der Fußpflege, die sollten nicht rausgegeben werden?
Kleines Rätselpraktisch, der Fall ist gelöst, das ist durch...
Nein, der Fall ist anhängig.
Der ist anhängig. Donald Lütjen, ja, sollen die Termine des Regierenden Bürgermeisters rausgegeben werden oder nicht? Also ich würde lieber seine Privaten eigentlich wissen wollen.
Ja, da haste schlechte Karten.
Das Leben ist wirklich hart. Wo setzt es denn noch an, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz? Weil wir haben eben gesagt, es gibt sowieso alles, was mich persönlich betrifft, da habe ich sowieso schon das Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung. Das heißt, die müssen eh alles rausrücken, wo mein Name drauf steht. Wofür brauche ich es dann noch? Also wofür wird es benutzt hauptsächlich?
Also das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist ums... Man muss es leider juristisch ausdrücken, wenn man das noch mal anders benennen will, ist ein voraussetzungsloses Akteneinsichtsrecht. Das heißt immer dann, wenn eben keine persönliche Betroffenheit da ist, die eine Einsicht legitimieren würde, dann kann man sozusagen aus Neugierde oder aus politischem Interesse Informationen beantragen. Und da gibt es doch durchaus eine ganze Menge Sachen, die mich interessieren könnten. Also beispielsweise die Bundeswehr lässt ja jetzt ihre Panzer von privaten Firmen warten. Vielleicht habe ich meinen Arbeitsplatz verloren, weil ich vorher bei der Bundeswehr war. Machen die das wirklich? Ja, das machen die.
Die Bundeswehr, aber das ist doch die Bundeswehr. Die können doch nicht, dass das die Bundeswehr ist. Ja, aber das ist doch die Bundeswehr. Die kann doch nicht... Wahnsinn, wo wohne ich hier? Ja, Entschuldigung.
Da ist die Frage, ob man sozusagen, kann man in diese Verträge Einblick nehmen. Das würde mich doch mal sehr interessieren. Das wäre also einer der Anträge, die mich interessieren würden. Dann in Hessen, da haben wir ja leider noch keinen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, aber da wollen die ja das erste privat betriebene Gefängnis aufmachen. Da würde mich ja auch entsprechende Informationen interessieren. Also da gibt es schon einige Sachen.
Wahrscheinlich die meistgefragtesten oder die am heiß begehrtesten Unterlagen werden die Mautverträge sein, vermutlich mal zur Lkw-Maut.
Die sind jetzt beantragt worden von Jörg Taus.
Aber das ist doch, ist das dann wieder ein privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen? Also wirtschaftliche Interessen, die da gefährdet werden könnten?
Das ist im Prinzip eine hoheitliche Aktion, hoheitliche Maßnahmen, die da durchgeführt wird. Also das ist denke ich mal auch ein Grenzbereich. Es besteht ja auch die Möglichkeit, dass nicht die gesamte Akte rausgegeben wird, sondern dass nur Teile davon rausgegeben werden oder dass auch bestimmte Stellen geschwärzt werden. Oder zum Beispiel, dass auch Firmennamen pseudonymisiert werden oder dass dann nur noch von Firma A, B und C die Rede ist. Denke ich, so weit so eine Möglichkeit gibt es für die Behörden auch.
Wäre doch auch immer schön vielleicht die Akten herausgeben zu lassen, die die Regierung, also die Kopien der Akten, die die Regierung Kohl in der letzten Nacht ihrer Amtszeit durch den Schredder gejagt hat. Da soll ja auch, weiß ich nicht, da sollen ja irgendwo Kopien noch rumliegen. Ich weiß es nicht, wahrscheinlich stimmt das alles gar nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist das nur eine Verschwörungstheorie. Kurze Durchsage an die Anrufenden hier. Wir sitzen hier nicht mit zehn Leuten an der Hotline. Das heißt, wenn ihr es klingeln lasst und es irgendwie fünfmal geklingelt hat und dann noch keiner rangegangen ist, dann heißt das nicht, dass nie mehr jemand rangehen wird, sondern dann heißt das, der Matthias, der Einbeinige, der draußen an der Fritz-Hotline sitzt, der telefoniert gerade mit einem von euch. Also ruft gerne weiter an, 0331 70 97 110 und lasst ordentlich klingeln. Früher oder später wird jemand euren Anruf annehmen. 0331 70 97 110. In welche behördlichen Dokumente würdet ihr jetzt gerne Einsicht nehmen? Ihr dürft nämlich Einsicht nehmen. Hyfo.
Hyfo? Und zwar sag ich mal Stichwort unseres Bundestagsvertreters. Die haben ja vor einiger Zeit war ja mal in der Presse auch mal ganz groß Gewesen gemacht worden bezüglich des Lobbyistentums. Wer wen im Bundestag eigentlich vertritt und so weiter und so fort. Da sollte ja auch mal ein Gesetz kommen, dass sozusagen solche Beziehungen oder solche finanziellen Interessen oder wie man das jetzt auch nennen mag, offenlegt sozusagen diese Beverdienstbescheidigung, was der Bundestagsverordnete an Einkommen hat, mit wem er sozusagen.
So die sogenannten Lebenverdienste, ne?
Genau, da gab es aber mal eine Zeit lang ziemlich das Gewisse, aber irgendwo ziemlich untergegangen in letzter Zeit. Da ist meine Frage eigentlich, könnte ich jetzt sage ich mal im Bundestag oder wo auch immer so eine Anfrage stellen über meinen Abgeordneten, sage ich mal in meinem Wahlkreis, wen er denn zum Beispiel vertritt?
Ja, dafür taugt das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz leider nichts. Das muss ich mir noch mal kurz erklären. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz gilt auch für den Bundestag, aber nur für die Bundestagsverwaltung. Denn das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz gilt für die Exekutive, es gilt nicht für die Legislative. Allerdings gibt es ja inzwischen Vorschriften und die werden ja auch noch weiter bearbeitet zur Veröffentlichung der Gehälter und es gibt auch Lobbyistenregister, aber das ist ein ganz wichtiges Thema. Da möchte ich auch auf eine weitere Organisation verweisen, auf Transparency International. Die bemühen sich sehr darum, dass da mehr Licht ins Dunkel kommt. Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Thema. Aber dafür brauchen wir eine andere Gesetzgebung, nicht das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
Okay, dann hätte ich noch eine andere Frage, wenn ich dich mal einfragen könnte. Es ist ja eben schon einmal ganz kurz das Thema Kohle angegriffen worden. Der Herr Kohle ist ja durch einen Unterausschuss gegangen und so weiter. Wegen seiner berühmten Ehrenwort. Ist die Frage, ob man solcherlei Unterausschussakten, die sich teilweise unter Parlamentsausschuss akten, ob man die einsehen kann. Aber ich denke aber auch nicht. Vermutlich wird man dann wie auch bei den Staatsjakten auf diese berühmte Persönlichkeit pochen und sagen, es ist auch eine Ausnahme.
Zunächst mal diese Akten, das muss man ganz formalistisch ansehen. Diese Akten sind im Besitz des Bundestages. Und zwar nicht der Bundestagsverwaltung, sondern sozusagen in dem legislativen Teil des Bundestages, nicht in dem Teil, der organisiert wieder die Reinigungsdienste und ähnliches läuft. Und sind deswegen vom Anwendungsbereich des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes nicht betroffen. Da kann ich nur sagen, entweder sollen die Bundestagsabgeordneten sich entschließen, diese Informationen rauszugeben oder wir müssen uns entschließen, vielleicht neue Abgeordnete zu wählen. Ich finde auch, dass der Bundestag transparenter agieren sollte, als er es tut.
Ja, aber wir wählen noch seit 40 Jahren neue Abgeordnete und es passiert nichts.
Ja, das ist richtig. Da die Alternative fehlt, könnte man sagen. Immerhin haben wir jetzt mit den Informationsfreiheitsgesetzen auf Landes- und auf Bundesebene Fortschritte. Das muss man ja mal sehen, auch wenn sozusagen noch einiges zu tun bleibt.
Politik ist ein unglaublich langwieriges Geschäft.
Ich muss sagen, was Sie jetzt als Fortschritt bezeichnet haben, das sieht für mich eher nach einem Krümel hingeschmissen aus. Ich sag erst mal zu Anfang, was Sie gesagt haben, bis zu 500 Euro Verfahrensgedür. Danke, ich werde mich jetzt, wenn ich bin zu merken, was in meiner Heimatstadt geht, ich werde mich wohl kommen zum Bauernzentrallen und sagen, ich lege jetzt erst mal 500 Euro auf den Tisch und möchte gern mal was sehen. Nur mit der Maßgabe lege ich erst mal auf den Tisch und der andere sagt dann vielleicht, nö.
Nein, nein, so ist es nicht, nein, nein. Also es ist so, erstens schonmal sind die 500 Euro die Obergrenze. Wobei, ja, sind erst mal die Obergrenze. Und das Zweite ist, die Information, erst mal muss gesagt werden, dass man gebühren möchte und dann hast du die Möglichkeit zu entscheiden, ob du das Verfahren weiterverfolgen möchtest. Das ist also nicht so, dass du da...
Oder möglichst Einspruch oder Widerspruch gegen die Gebühren...
Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, die Gebühren abzusenken, auch gegen Null abzusenken, wenn das ein Fall ist, von dem man denkt, dass das wichtig wäre. Also das kann man schon sehr gut nutzen.
Ja, aber ich sag mal, alles was interessant... Gut, wenn wir das noch halbwegs abgedenken sind, sag ich mal so, anhand der Ausnahmeregelungen, die ja nämlich schon mehrfach auch aufgezählt wurden, sei es eben das Datenschottsgesetz, sei es das Gesetz zum Schotts von Filmen, Privatpersonen, weiß der Geier, ist dieses Gesetz eigentlich so ziemlich Null. Weil ich denke, es wird vielleicht für jede Situation irgendwo auch eine Ausnahmeregelung in diesem Gesetz finden. Also mir fällt so kaum was auf den Stehgreif ein, was ich jetzt noch abfahren könnte.
Das Problem ist, dass überall da, wo der Bürger Machtmissbrauch vermutet, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz doch sehr stark eingeschränkt nur zur Geltung kommt, oder?
Es fühlt sich so an.
Also man muss vor allen Dingen sehen, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz sowohl auf Landes- als auch auf der Bundesebene ist ja jetzt hier in Deutschland noch sehr jung. Und jetzt kommt es darauf an, das Gesetz zu nutzen, auch mit dem Risiko, dass Anträge abgelehnt werden. Denn die Ablehnungen sind dann die Grundlage dafür, dieses Gesetz zu novellieren. Und wenn man sich in anderen Ländern umsieht, die schon diese Gesetze länger haben, dann sieht man auch, die haben in der Regel auch mit eher schwachen Gesetzen angefangen. Und dann muss man gucken, dass man dem politische Macht organisiert, diese Gesetze zu verbessern. Das ist nun mal das Bohren dicker Bretter.
Ja, und das hat auch noch ein Wort dazu. Also ich sag auch mal Politik. Politik ist ein sehr langwieriges Geschäft. Also das ist nichts, was instant funktioniert, habe ich gelernt. Das heißt, dass wir so ein Gesetz haben, ist tatsächlich ein Fortschritt. Also selbst wenn das Gesetz gerade mal das Papier nur wert sein sollte, auf dem es steht, was ich nicht glaube, es ist ein Fortschritt. Also auch wenn es sich irgendwie so anfühlt, als würde man irgendwie in so einem Honigtopf rumlaufen.
Also vor allem muss man sich auch mal in diese komplexe Materie reinversetzen, bis so ein Gesetz erst mal geschrieben wird. Und erst mal das, was man eigentlich will, versuchen, in Worte zu fassen. Hinterher stellt man fest, es ist halt irgendwie doch, wird alles doch anders verstanden oder die Praxis ist einfach anders. Insofern finde ich es eigentlich auch ziemlich gut, dass so eine Gesetze auch ein bisschen eine gewisse Dynamik haben. Oder dass wir jetzt einfach mal sagen, okay, wir testen es jetzt mal an, wir probieren die Grenzen aus. Und schauen dann mal, ob das damit gemeint war, mit dem Gesetz ursprünglich.
0331 70 97 110. Die Nummer der Fritz-Hotline, die Frage an euch. Erstens, welcher Information würde dir gerne die Freiheit geben? Jetzt wo es ein Gesetz gibt, der Information die Freiheit garantiert. Und Christoph würde ganz gerne wissen, ob denn der Terminkalender, also der dienstliche Terminkalender des Regierenden Bürgermeisters von Berlin veröffentlicht werden sollte oder ob nicht. Bitte mit Begründung, wir kommen dann auch nochmal rum, wir verteilen Noten hinterher. Das gilt gleichzeitig als Schein für die Uni. 0331 70 97 110. Guten Abend, Stefan.
Hallo.
Und zwar wollte ich wissen, ob man die Adresse anhand des Namens ermitteln kann. Ob ich zum Landeseinwohneramt laufen kann?
Das kannst du doch sowieso schon.
Das kann man machen.
Und dann würde ich gerne wissen, ob mein Gegenüber darüber informiert wird.
Dass ich Informationen...
Nö.
Also du meinst jetzt beim Landeseinwohneramt. Also wenn du hingehst und sagst, ich wüsste gerne, wo Holger Klein in Berlin wohnt, dann kriegst du diese Ausgabe. Ich glaube, das kostet 25 Euro oder so. Das ist vergleichsweise billig auf jeden Fall.
Du brauchst aber noch ein paar mehr Daten.
Ein Geburtsdatum glaub ich brauchst du noch. Ein Geburtsdatum und irgendeinen letzten bekannten Wohnort, also irgendeine Meldeadresse, eine alte.
Und ihr meintet ja, dass man auf alle Daten zugreifen könnte, die bei irgendwelchen Ämtern rumliegen.
Wie sieht es denn dann mit der Geburtsurkunde aus?
Deine eigene oder?
Ne, von irgendjemandem, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel Holger Klein.
Naja, ich kann es ja auch so fälschen. Also ich bin geboren am 08.09.1969 in Köln.
Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, das muss man ganz deutlich sagen, soll nicht das Werkzeug von Detekteien werden. Also es geht nicht darum, Menschen hinterherzuschnüffeln. Das ist so eine spezielle Frage, dass ich mich schwer damit tue, da eine ganz sichere Antwort zu geben. Aber ich gehe davon aus, wenn jemand sagt, wenn jemand zu einem Standesamt geht und sagt, ich hätte gerne die Geburtsregister des letzten Jahres, dass die den freundlichen Lächeln wieder rauskomplimentieren.
0331 77 97 110 hat angerufen, der Andreas.
Ich hab mal eine Frage. Und zwar könnte man irgendwie beim LKA oder BKA, ich weiß nicht, wer das macht, einsehen, ob die rosa Listen haben. Rosa Listen, also sind so Listen, die wurden früher mal, das kommt so aus der Nazizeit, da wurden irgendwie Schwule drauf geführt. Und das ist so ein bisschen auch noch weitergeführt worden in der Bundesrepublik. Speziell so im bayerischen Raum.
Entschuldigung, die sexuelle Orientierung. Zum Hintergrund, das war auch im Rahmen der Big Brother Awards, haben wir uns auch mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Es geht also darum, dass bei bestimmten Akten quasi ein Datenbankfeld ist, wo bestimmte Stichwörter eingegeben werden können, wenn es darum um die Vorgangsbearbeitung geht. Das heißt also z.B. bei der Bearbeitung von Anzeigen, Begriffe wie Milieustraftat oder sowas. Das ist nicht offensichtlich oder ganz klar, aber jeder Beamte weiß, was damit gemeint ist. Und da ist dieser Begriff Rosalisten gefallen. Und deine Frage wäre jetzt im Prinzip, da anzufragen, welche Datenbank-Fäder oder welche Sachen da genommen werden.
Also diese Information müsste nach meiner Einschätzung herausgegeben werden. Also du kriegst nicht die Liste der Berliner Schwulen, die irgendwo in der Liste stehen. Die Frage, ob diese Liste geführt oder nicht, muss natürlich rausgegeben werden.
Wobei ich kann mich erinnern, dass alle Bundesländer sich einig waren, oder alle LKA einig waren, dass es eigentlich nicht so eine gute Idee ist, dass es mehr oder weniger ein Versehen war, oder halt eine Taktlosigkeit.
Ein Versehen, dass es rausgekommen ist.
Möglicherweise, aber dass sich da keiner so richtig mit wohlfühlt. Aber es wäre vielleicht schon sinnvoll, da mal nachzufragen, ob das denn jetzt auch wirklich nicht mehr gemacht wird.
Interessant wären auch noch diese Einstellungskriterien.
Eine Sekunde, eine Zwischenfrage noch. Wie, Christoph, könnte ich denn... Also angenommen, Andreas geht hin und sagt mir mal, ob es diese Rosalisten gibt und ob nicht. Und die sagen, nee, gibt's nicht. Wie bin ich in der Lage, denen zu glauben? Also gibt es irgendetwas, was das glaubwürdig macht? Weil die können ja einfach sagen, nee, gibt's nicht, geh weg.
Wenn ich der Meinung bin, dass das Amt mir eine falsche Auskunft erteilt, dann würde ich immer empfehlen, zunächst mal zum Informationsfreiheitsbeauftragten zu gehen. Also in Berlin zu Herrn Ticks oder in Wannenburg zu Frau Hartke. Und die zu bitten, dass die das auch nochmal überprüft. Und wenn man auch dann noch nicht zufrieden ist, also vermutet, dass man falsch beauskunftet wurde, dann muss man vor dem Verwaltungsgericht Klage einreichen. Und sagen, ich möchte, dass festgestellt wird, dass die mich richtig oder eben falsch beauskunftet haben.
Weil da möglicherweise jetzt im ganz konkreten Fall der beste Weg wäre, vermute ich mal, dass du hingehst und fragst, ob es irgendeine Dienstanweisung gibt, die das eben untersagt, sowas zu machen. Oder die das eben befürwortet, sowas zu machen. Ob es irgendeine Handlungsanweisung gibt. Das wäre jetzt sowas, was mir spontan einfällt, um mal wirklich eine konkrete Antwort zu bekommen. Außer jetzt ein Ja oder Nein oder Nee eigentlich nicht. Sondern einfach zu fragen, ob es eine konkrete Dienstanweisung dafür gibt.
Andreas, ich hätte dich unterbrochen, Entschuldige.
Mir ist die Frage schon weggestellt, ich wollte kein Problem.
Hättest du ja aufschreiben können, Mensch.
Okay.
Nun denn, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. 0331 77 97 110, welchen Informationen würde dir gerne die Freiheit wiedergeben? Und soll der Terminkalender von... Wovereit, ich hab Wovereits Vornamen vergessen, siehste? Weil man eben immer nur Wovie nennt. Klaus Wovereit, Klaus Wovereit vom Regierenden Bürgermeister von Berlin, soll dieser dienstliche Terminkalender veröffentlicht werden. 0331 77 97 110. Guten Abend, Patrick.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur ganz kurz einen Kommentar zu loswerden, zu dem vorletzten Kommentar, genau. Da ging es um Standesamt und solche Geschichten. Und also alle Ämter, die jetzt zur Stadt gehören, die dürften ja gar nicht unter das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz fallen, weil das doch eigentlich zum Bund gehört.
Richtig, aber zumindestens für die Hörer in Berlin und Brandenburg gibt es die Möglichkeit schon seit ein paar Jahren, es weiß nun niemand davon.
Ja, das wollte ich eigentlich nochmal sagen. Danke, Patrick.
Das heißt, der Föderalismus verhindert, dass die Bürger ihre Rechte vernünftig wahrnehmen können?
Der Föderalismus schlägt voll zu, ja. Das heißt, das Bundesgesetz gilt tatsächlich nur für Bundesämter und die Landesgesetze für die Landesämter und die Kommunen.
Können wir nicht mal ein Chaosradio zur Abschaffung des Föderalismus machen? Oh, gleich habe ich Verfassungsschutz am Hals. Ja, 0331 70 97 110 seid ihr weiterhin eingeladen anzurufen.
Was mich interessieren würde von Christoph ist, wir hatten ja vorhin auch schon darüber gesprochen, es gab im Vorfeld der Verabschiedung des Gesetzes, des Beschlusses, gab es eine ziemlich breit angelegte Kampagne. Der eine von einer oder andere von euch kann sich vielleicht auch an große Werbeplakate erinnern. Da wurde für Informationsfreiheit Werbung gemacht. Es gab große Plakate. Das Ganze war initiiert von einer Bertelsmann Stiftung, wo ich mit ein paar Leuten mal drüber gesprochen habe und es eigentlich nicht so ganz klar war, was hat die Bertelsmann Stiftung eigentlich für ein Interesse daran. Oder wo kommt es her? Kannst du da kurz was zu sagen, wie das entstanden ist?
Wir müssen ja gleich Nachrichten machen. Wollen wir das als Teaser für Nach-die-Nachrichten benutzen? Die Bertelsmann Stiftung.
Okay, vielleicht ist es aber auch kurz, oder?
Die Antwort ist insofern wirklich sehr kurz. Ich kann die Motivation der Bertelsmann Stiftung nicht kommentieren. Das weiß ich einfach nicht. Die haben sich da sehr toll für eingesetzt. Wieso müssen die beantworten?
Mist, hätten wir es doch bis nach den Nachrichten stehen lassen sollen. Wir haben gerade noch was hübsches gefunden im Internet und zwar gibt es einen Preis, die Journalisten des Jahres, der Goldene Prometheus heißt dieser Preis, der wird irgendwann jetzt demnächst verliehen. Wir haben einfach mal auf den Link Partner geklickt, also die Partner dieser Preisverleihung, unter anderem Partner der Preisverleihung, AOL, British American Tobacco, die BP, die CMA, die ENBW, der Gesamtmetall, wie heißen die? Arbeitgeberverband Gesamtmetall oder so ähnlich. Der grüne Punkt, die KfW-Bankengruppe Microsoft, MLP, Novartis, Rehmzmer ist dabei, die RWE, Shell, Toll Collect, Wattenfall, Volkswagen und die Vestalby. Und jetzt gibt's richtige Nachrichten.
Die exklusiven Fritz-Radio-Konzerte gehen weiter und weiter. Die einen kommen extra aus Koblenz. Die anderen kommen extra aus Hamburg. Und wo treffen sie sich? Fritz präsentiert ein exklusives Radio-Konzert mit Blackmail. Und Tomte. Blackmail und Tomte, das exklusive Radiokonzert live in den Friststuhl. Morgen Abend ab 20 Uhr und im Radio.
Fritz vom RBB.
2,512. Mit Matthias Kerkov.
In der BND Irak-Affäre wird es vorerst keinen parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss geben. FDP und Linkspartei haben es nicht geschafft, einen entsprechenden Gruppenantrag durchzubringen. Beide Parteien erreichten nur 125 Stimmen, 154 wären aber nötig gewesen. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel will den Bürokratieabbau voranbringen. In ihrer Eröffnungsrede auf dem Weltwirtschaftsforum im schweizerischen Davos sagte sie, die Vereinfachung der Verwaltung werde ein Hauptthema der deutschen EU-Präsidentschaft 2007 sein. Merkel bekräftigte ihr Ziel, Deutschland in den nächsten 10 Jahren wieder in die Spitzengruppe in Europa zu führen. Die Bundesregierung hat weiterhin kein Lebenszeichen von den beiden im Irak entführten deutschen Ingenieuren. Wie Bundesaußenminister Steinmeier mitteilte, gibt es bislang auch keinen Kontakt zu den Entführern. Inzwischen steht das sächsische Unternehmen zunehmend in der Kritik, weil es seine beiden Mitarbeiter in den Irak leisen ließ. Zum Sport im Viertelfinale des DFB-Pokals gab es am Abend folgende Ergebnisse. Aminia Bielefeld Kickers Offenbach 4 zu 2 im Elfmeterschießen, 1860 Müncheneintracht Frankfurt 1 zu 3 und St. Pauli Werder Bremen 3 zu 1. Es sind jetzt Bayern München, Bielefeld, Frankfurt und St. Pauli im Halbfinale. In dieser Nacht wechseln wolkig Temperaturen zwischen minus 5 und minus 10 Grad. Morgen wird es dann wieder heiter bis wolkig, meist trocken bei Höchstwerten zwischen minus 5 und minus 2 Grad. Wir haben keine aktuellen Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Matthias Kerkov, 4 Minuten nach halb 12.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6 dann Fritz in Berlin.
Chaosradio 109 mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und euch am Telefon unter 0331 77 97 110. Ihr seid immer noch eingeladen, kund zu tun, welcher Information, die bei Behörden liegt, ihr gerne die Freiheit geben wollen würdet und ob Klaus Wover als Terminkalender, also der dienstliche Terminkalender des regierenden Bürgermeisters von Berlin veröffentlicht werden sollte oder nicht. Bitte mit Begründung, es gibt Noten hinterher. Ähm, fragen wir doch mal die Fachleute, Frank, welche, welche Information, welche Information möchtest du die Freiheit geben?
Also wir als CCC haben uns ja in der letzten Zeit mit dem elektronischen Reisepass, mit dem biometrischen Pass beschäftigt und in dem Zusammenhang sind ein paar Fragen offen geblieben. Es gibt da einige Dokumente, es gibt da einige Studien, wo zum Beispiel diese Systeme, diese Fingerabdrucksysteme und Gesichtserkennungssysteme mal untersucht worden sind und dazu gibt es einen Abschlussbericht. Es gibt das Ergebnis, wo grob drin steht, naja, naja, ist nicht so doll, aber könnte man vielleicht noch und es gibt ein paar interessante Anhänge dazu. Die sind aber nicht öffentlich. Diesen Anhängen wird zum Beispiel berichtet über die Sicherheit, die Fälschungssicherheit von diesen Fingerabdrucksystemen und da waren wir als CCC auch ein bisschen aktiv und haben da auch gezeigt, wie leicht man so eine Sache umgehen kann, zumindest die Fingerabdrucksysteme, die wir in den Händen bekommen haben, die konnten wir auch alle ziemlich leicht überwinden. Das heißt, wir konnten mit einem gefälschten Finger uns für jemand anders ausgeben. Und jetzt sind diese ganzen Sachen auch noch mal professionell getestet worden von einer Firma, die diese Studie gemacht hat. Und wir wollen natürlich jetzt gerne wissen, wie sieht es aus? Wie sicher sind die Sachen eigentlich? Wie sicher wird diese Technik sein, die wir ab nächstem Jahr an den Grenzen und in den Melderemptern zu stehen haben? Dieser Anhang ist jetzt nicht öffentlich gekennzeichnet und wir wollen natürlich aber trotzdem gerne mal wissen, was steht da eigentlich drin. Das heißt, wir wollen vielleicht auch gar nicht die konkreten Firmennamen wissen. Uns reicht es auch, wenn da drin steht, Firma A, B und C hat verloren, weil deren Systeme waren leicht austrickbar, austrickbar, ähm, listbar, ähm, auszutricksen. Genau. Und ja, das ist eine Sache, die wir gerne mal wissen wollen. Und da werden wir jetzt auch einen entsprechenden Antrag formulieren. Wir rechnen erst mal damit, dass der abgelehnt wird. Aber wir versuchen da hart zu bleiben.
Ich glaube, das ist ja dann die Sicherheit der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, die da tankiert wird, im Zweifelsfall, oder?
Das ist die Frage.
Wenn die Dinger sowieso unsicher sind nicht, ja. Dann beißt sich die Katze dann doch einigermaßen in den Schwanz.
Also die Frage ist dann natürlich, ob denn auf Basis von solchen Gutachten auch überhaupt so ein System eingeführt werden kann. Das wäre dann vielleicht nochmal an anderen Stellen nachzufragen, welche Informationen da vorgelegen haben. Das ist jetzt natürlich beschlossen worden. Das ist an sich alles ein bisschen spät. Aber wir können natürlich nochmal im Nachhinein versuchen, die Sache ein bisschen aufzurollen und dann noch mal ein paar Erklärungen einzufordern.
Es gibt jetzt die Informationsfreiheitsgesetze. In vier Bundesländern gab es sie bereits. Bevor das Bundesinformationsfreiheitsgesetze, jetzt wird hier mal länger dieses Wort, gibt es da irgendwie Erfahrungen? Also wie ist das gelaufen?
Die Erfahrungen in den Bundesländern, ich wiederhole es nochmal, Berlin, Brandenburg, Nordrhein-Westfalen und Schleswig-Holstein sind überall positiv. Sie werden von allen Beteiligten als positiv geschätzt.
Also auch von denen, die es vorher vielleicht kritisiert haben, nicht haben wollten.
Genau, die sehen auch alle ein, dass die Schreckgespenster, die an die Wand gemalt wurden von überlaufenden Ämtern, überhaupt nicht eingetroffen sind. Und es gibt auch keine Beispiele für den Missbrauch des Rechts. Es wurde immer wieder gesagt, es könnte ja irgendwie missbraucht werden. Was ist bisher nicht missbraucht worden? Also die berühmten Querulanten sind noch nicht aufgetaucht.
Also was wäre denn der Missbrauch? Ich wollte gerade fragen, wie kann man es missbrauchen?
Ich sehe ja auch überhaupt nicht so richtig, wie man es missbrauchen kann. Es ist irgendwie schwierig. Also es ist auch bisher überhaupt nichts vorgekommen. Also zumindest ist mir nichts zu Ohren gekommen. Und ich kenne auch aus den Berichten, die veröffentlicht werden, keine entsprechenden Hinweise. Dafür gibt es aber durchaus spannende Berichte darüber, was auch schon für Anträge gestellt worden sind. Also ich finde sehr spannende Antrag aus Berlin, der sozusagen uns alle als Mieter betrifft. Wir stören ja alle unter der berühmten zweiten Miete der Nebenkosten, die zu nicht unwesentlichen Teilen auch aus den Kosten für die Wasserversorgung bestehen. Und in Berlin sind die Wasserwerke teil privatisiert worden. Die gehören jetzt zu 49 Prozent einem privaten Unternehmen. Und die These von der Berliner Wohnungswirtschaft ist, dass der Erlös, der für die Privatisierung erzielt wurde, der Preis, der erzielt wurde, überhöht war, über dem Marktwert dieser 49 Prozent lag und dass dieser überhöhte Preis damit durchgesetzt wurde, dass dem Unternehmen zugestanden wird, jetzt überhöhte Wasserpreise zu nehmen. Dass wir sozusagen indirekt eine Steuereinsubvention an unsere Regierung bezahlen über überhöhte Wasserpreise, womit dann dieser erhöhte Kaufpreis finanziert wurde. Und deswegen haben die einen Antrag gestellt und wollen wissen, wie die Wasserpreise von den Berliner Wasserwerken kalkuliert werden, um das nachzuprüben. Das finde ich ist eine sehr spannende Sache.
Und der Tag, wenn 51 Prozent in privater Hand wären, würde das nicht mehr funktionieren, oder?
Das weiß ich gar nicht. Das ist nämlich eine ganz kippliche Frage, wie weit der Geltungsbereich geht in dem Informationsfreiheitsgesundheit. Da muss man dann ganz genau in die Formulierung für den Anwendungsbereich kommen. Steht dann was von öffentlichen Stellen und die Frage ist, ob eine Stelle, die als Monopolist auftritt und auch die Grundversorgung wahrnimmt, ob das dann notwendigerweise eine öffentliche Stelle sein muss. Eine klare Lösung gibt es in Südafrika, da steht ganz klar im Gesetz drin. Wenn ich Informationen brauche, um meine persönlichen Rechte wahrzunehmen, dann müssen die auch von Unternehmen herausgegeben werden.
Das ist eindeutig. 0331 70 97 1 60, ihr seid weiterhin eingeladen anzurufen, zu erzählen, welche Informationen ihr die Freiheit geben wollen würdet. Nina, guten Abend.
Ja, guten Abend. Meine Frage wäre, wie sieht denn das aus mit abgeschlossenen Ermittlungsverfahren bei der Polizei?
Das ist eine Frage, da bin ich unsicher, das weiß ich nicht genau, ob die zugänglich sind. Im Prinzip, würde ich sagen, müssten die zumindest teilweise zugänglich sein, denn Informationsfreiheitsgesetze kennen das sogenannte Trennungsprinzip. Das heißt, wenn eine Akte angefordert wird, in der sensible Informationen drinstecken, die nicht rausgegeben werden können, dann muss dieser sensible Teil von dem zugänglichen Teil getrennt werden durch Schwerzung oder andere Techniken und der Rest muss zugänglich gemacht werden. Und insofern würde ich sagen, gilt das auch für Ermittlungsakten. Das heißt, das heißt, das heißt jedem, das heißt, also wenn ich über eine Ermittlung Bescheid wissen möchte, muss das im Prinzip möglich sein. Aber da muss man eben sehr genau gucken, was für eine Art von Ermittlung das ist. Wir wollen natürlich nicht, dass die Leute, die durch unsere Polizei beobachtet werden, sollen sich durch Informationsfreiheitsgesetze diese Beobachtung entziehen können.
Also es wäre denn aber noch ein laufendes Verfahren und kein abgeschlossenes wahrscheinlich, wenn sie noch beobachtet werden.
Ja, das muss man dann gucken. Das ist wirklich eine sehr knifflige Sache. Da muss man die genauen Umstände kennen. Dazu bin ich auch zu wenig mit der Aktenführung bei der Polizei vertraut, um da jetzt Stellung nehmen zu können. Ich kann nur empfehlen, sich in solchen Fällen an den Informationsfreiheitsbeauftragten zu wenden, die da sehr gut berät. Der kann ihnen da weiterhelfen.
Ich bin jetzt mal neugierig, warum fragst du, Nina?
Weil ich persönlich betroffen bin und...
Das heißt, gegen dich wurde ermittelt?
Ne. Das Haus meiner Eltern ist abgebrannt und ich war halt mit im Haus und es wurde halt ermittelt und auch festgestellt, dass da halt Spiritus mit im Spiel war und dass es halt kein Kabel Brand war etc. und ich wurde halt auch mehrere Male selbst vorgeladen, hab also so die vage Vermutung, dass ich da für die Polizei in Frage gekommen bin, war es aber nicht und würde einfach gerne so für mich genauere Kenntnisse haben, um das halt irgendwo abschließen zu können.
Aber dann müssen die das nicht ohnehin rausgeben?
Also ich mein, wenn es über einen Anwalt geht, hat der keinen...
Also auch auf Anfrage nicht, deswegen finde ich das recht spannend.
Also ich bin ja jetzt ein bisschen verunsichert, also grundsätzlich würde ich sagen, müssen diese Informationen, also gerade was dich selbst betrifft, herausgegeben werden. Ich nehme mal ein anderes Beispiel, was etwas ähnlich gelagert ist. Also wenn beispielsweise eine Person überwacht wird, also beispielsweise das Telefon auch überwacht wird und diese Überwachung abgeschlossen ist und diese Person dann nicht irgendwie belangt wird, dann muss diese Person auch in Kenntnis darüber gesetzt werden.
Soll.
Aber ich will ja nicht nur sagen, so ist die Rechtslage, ja? Also wenn jemand Verdächtiger ist, das ist ja überhaupt nicht ehrenrörig, wir wissen alle, wenn bestimmte Straftaten begangen werden, dass immer bestimmte Gruppen von Leuten routinemäßig abgeklopft werden, sag ich jetzt mal. Und deswegen ist es auch nach meiner Meinung ganz legitim, hinterher nachzufragen, was dabei herausgekommen ist, nicht, dass man dann noch irgendwie einen Tag in der Akte stehen hat und potenzieller Brandstifter zu sein. Also ich wiederhole meine Empfehlung, bitte, wenn das nicht klappt, an den Datenschutzbeauftragten gehen, der hilft.
Aber es ist jetzt relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass die jetzt beispielsweise, also es kommt dann noch jemand anderes in Frage, so nach meiner Meinung, und ich weiß, dass die in die Richtung ermittelt haben. Wäre jetzt aber für mich natürlich nicht möglich, in irgendeiner Weise ein Erfahrungen zu bringen, ob die da jetzt weitergekommen sind in der Sache. Die Polizei könnte ja jetzt annehmen, ich würde jetzt Rache üben wollen.
Also ich denke bei den Personennamen wird es da natürlich nicht geben, gegen wen da weiter ermittelt wird.
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist in der Tat eine Sache, zumal der Fall ja noch nicht aufgeklärt ist. Also da kann die Polizei natürlich nicht einen Einblick in ihre Akten geben, solange sie noch ermittelt. Da muss man also wirklich sehr genau gucken, was da zu welchen Zeitpunkten rausgegeben werden kann. Also irgendwann wird ja so eine Akte auch geschlossen. Aber das ist wirklich eine sehr spezifische und knifflige Frage. Da will ich gar keine falschen Ratschläge geben. Also da kann ich wirklich nur an Fachleute verweisen.
Dann gute Nacht, Nina.
Danke, tschüss.
Wir auch, aber hauptsächlich ihr mit Chaosradio 109 im Blumen auf Fritz. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist unser Thema. Und Frank, ansage mir frisch, wie wir erreicht werden können.
Genau, wenn ihr nämlich nicht anrufen wollt, weil ihr entweder nicht durchkommt, keine Lust habt ihr anzurufen oder warum auch immer, ihr könnt uns eine Mail schicken an chaosradio.ccc.de oder wir haben so eine Nummer geschaltet, das sogenannte Feedback-Telefon. Ich hab das auch persönlich noch nie probiert, aber das... Das Feedback?
Warte mal, sag mal die Nummer.
Das ist 080...
Ich muss mal gucken, wie das hier funktioniert. Sekunde mal, so.
018019933229955 Willst du mich verarschen, was ist das für eine Nummer?
55. So, jetzt müsste ich eigentlich, wenn ich hier auf On Air drücke, passiert gar nichts. Doch.
Hallo, du hast die richtige Nummer gewählt, um zum Chaosradio-Feedback durchzudringen.
Das war Tim.
Ja, lass doch bitte deine Wünsche, deine Vorgesäge, oder Kritik oder sonstige Anlegerung oder was du ihm auch gerade so einfällst. Chaosradio, hier auf dem System. Wir hören uns das dann an und mal schauen, vielleicht bauen wir dann auch in eine der nächsten Sendungen ein.
Hallo Feedback. Warte mal, ein Feedback. Ich mach mal ein Feedback.
Nee, aber am ersten, ihr könnt sogar richtig sinnvolle Sachen auch als Feedback hinterlassen. Wir freuen uns darüber, wir hören uns das an und bauen das dann auch bei der nächstbesten Gelegenheit in den Chaosradio Express vielleicht sogar ein.
Und wenn ihr Fragen habt zum Informationsfreiheitsgesetz bzw. unsere Fragen gerne beantworten würdet, dann seid ihr herzlich eingeladen anzurufen unter 033 177 97 110. Die Nummer der Fritzotline ist das. Die Fragen an euch waren, welcher Information würdet ihr gerne zur Freiheit verhelfen, jetzt wo es ja ein Gesetz gibt, das die Informationen frei macht. Also stellt euch vor, die Behörde bei euch um die Ecke, welche auch immer das sein mag, die arbeitet so vor sich hin und schreibt das, was sie da so arbeitet, in große Akten rein. Und diese Akten verschwinden dann irgendwann im Keller. Und ihr fragt euch vielleicht, was haben die denn da eigentlich gearbeitet den ganzen Tag? Und genau in diese Akten könnt ihr jetzt reingucken. Was würde euch interessieren? Welche Arbeit der Behörde? Was zum Beispiel das Bauamt? Also ich weiß, bei meinen Eltern da draußen, die wohnen auf dem Land, unten in der Nähe von Köln, da bauen die den ganzen Tag, die bauen ständig irgendwelche Verkehrsberuhigungen. Dann mal hier hin, mal da hin, mal rechts auf die Straße, mal links auf die Straße, dann reißen sie wieder weg. Und so, das wäre so eine Akte, wo ich gerne mal reingucken würde.
Ich würde mal interessieren, was die auf der Warschauer Straße, auf der Brücke die ganze Zeit machen. Diese Straße ist irgendwie seit Jahren nur aufgerissen.
Ja, ich, schuldige mal, guck dir bitte mal die Berlins Prachtboulevard Nummer 1 an. Unter den Linden, ich wohne seit 1997 in Berlin. Und seitdem ist diese Straße eine Baustelle. Und dann fragen die sich, warum keine Touristen kommen.
Es gibt übrigens auch zum Palast der Republik, gibt's, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine offizielle Anfrage nach IFGs, aber da gibt's halt auch ein Gutachten, eine Machbarkeitsstudie wohl, die aber auch nicht rausgegeben wurde vom Senat, weil es heißt, es ist halt eine private, von einer privaten Firma gemacht worden. Und man würde möglicherweise deren Urheberrechte verletzen, wenn man die rausgibt, wie ich die verstanden hab.
Aber das ist doch von meinem Geld bezahlt worden.
Christoph, weißt du was über die Studie, hast du da von denen was gehört?
Über diese Studie, ich hab's ja von der Studie gehört. Und die Gutachten, die im Rahmen von irgendwelchen Entscheidungsprozessen eingeholt werden, sind ein klassisches Beispiel dafür, was auf jeden Fall herausgegeben werden muss. Ausnahme gibt es natürlich auch hier. Also angenommen jetzt, ich geh jetzt mal auf das berühmte Mautsystem. Wenn also in irgendeinem Angebot oder in einem Gutachten irgendein spezielles geschütztes technisches Verfahren offengelegt wird, wie man irgendwas, was ich, einen Nummernschild abtastet oder sowas in der Art, dann mag das unter Objekten als Geschäftsgeheimnis geschützt sein. Aber ein Gutachten insgesamt, was sagt, das funktioniert oder das funktioniert nicht, muss natürlich zugänglich sein.
Und wenn ich jetzt sowas wissen will, wie fange ich sowas an? Also wie schreibe ich jetzt konkret diesen Antrag? Also ich habe jetzt so ein leeres Blatt Papier vor mir. Da schreibe ich irgendwie meinen Namen rauf als Absende. Ich besuche mir die Behörde raus. Ich vermute mal, das ist vielleicht das, keine Ahnung, Bauamt Berlin, Senatsbauverwaltung. Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, Datum Berlin, Datum sehr geehrte Damen und Herren. Hiermit beantrage ich nach dem Berliner Informationsfreiheitsgesetz Einsicht in die Akten.
Also so kompliziert muss man das gar nicht machen. Die Informationsfreiheitsgesetze bestehen noch nicht einmal auf der schriftlichen Form. Es reicht völlig aus, wenn man das denn möchte, entweder hinzugehen oder anzurufen und zu sagen, ich möchte gerne. Ich würde es natürlich für sinnvoll halten, das schriftlich zu machen, aber man kann es mündlich machen. Und wenn es schriftlich gemacht wird, ist es formlos zu machen. Also man kann ganz einfach aufschreiben, ich möchte auf Grundlage des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes gerne folgende Informationen von Ihnen haben. Und dann muss man natürlich beschreiben, was man haben möchte. Das muss derjenige, der das bearbeitet, verstehen können. Weitere Anforderungen gibt es nicht.
So, und dann vergehen, sagen wir mal zwei Wochen, dann kommt eine Anfrage, sehr geehrter Herr Rosengard, wir haben folgende Dokumente und können Ihnen die entweder zuschicken. Und als Kopien berechnen wir 10 Cent pro Seite oder so was. Macht, summa summarum, 45 Euro. Möchten Sie das ja oder nein?
Genau, so läuft das. Und wenn es innerhalb von zwei Wochen ginge, wäre das schon schnell. Also in den Gesetzen steht drin unverzüglich, was auf Juristendeutsch heißt, ohne schuldhaftes Zögern.
Also auf Schabowski-Deutsch heißt es jetzt.
Ja gut, also auf jeden Fall, es soll möglichst bald, aber auf jeden Fall innerhalb von vier Wochen zugänglich gemacht werden. Dann gibt es natürlich noch die eine oder andere Möglichkeit, diesen Zeitraum etwas zu strecken. Aber die Erfahrung lehrt. In den meisten Fällen geht das einigermaßen flott, die Informationen zu bekommen.
Vielleicht geht ihnen der Arsch auf Grund, also dann geht das große Zittern. Da will ein Bürger, der will was wissen. Dass sie dann so schnell reagieren, vielleicht? Ich habe eine Überraschung, dass so was Neues...
Lass doch mal die Arme... Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, warum du immer so die Behörden bist. Wirklich, die tun doch nichts.
Ja eben.
Nein, ihr sollt nicht so schlecht reden über die Behörden. Also ich hab ja in den verschiedensten Veranstaltungen zu tun, auch natürlich dann mit den Interessenvertretern von den Behörden. Als die Interessenvertreter sind natürlich für mich immer unangenehme Gesprächspartner, weil die im Zusammenhang mit den Gesetzgebungsverfahren natürlich probieren, diese Gesetze eher klein zu halten. Aber die einzelnen Mitarbeiter in den Behörden, da gibt es eine ganze Reihe, die ganz vernünftig mit diesen Gesetzen umgehen. Allerdings muss man auch sagen, es gibt natürlich ganz viele von den Damen und Herren, die noch überhaupt nicht wissen, dass es diese Gesetze gibt. Also nicht nur wir auf der Straße wissen das nicht, sondern auch die Damen und Herren, die in den Ämtern arbeiten, wissen das nicht. Deswegen darf man da nicht gleich unfreundlich sein, wenn die nicht Bescheid wissen. Auch unsere Bundesministerien, ich hab das extra noch mal gecheckt vor der Sendung, auf den Webseiten unserer Bundesministerien gibt es außer beim Auswärtigen Amt leider noch überhaupt keinen Hinweis auf die Existenz des neuen Bundesinformationsfreiheitsgesetzes. Nur beim Auswärtigen Amt, aber da muss man auch zwei, drei Klicks suchen.
Ist das Trägheit oder ist das der Wille zu verschleiern?
Ich würde Trägheit sagen.
Vielleicht gibt es ja sogar auch Behördenmitarbeiter, die auf Informationen sitzen und sagen, hoffentlich fragt das mal jemand an. Das ist so brisant, das muss an die Öffentlichkeit. Ich kann es nicht machen, bitte Bürger fragt an.
Ja, also in Berlin gibt es ein schönes Beispiel wieder. Vielleicht haben das einige noch in Erinnerung. Es gab mal einen Skandal, nachdem unsere Regierin der Bürgermeister Woverait den Vorsitz geführt hat im Bundesrat und dieses halbe Jahr vorbei war, hat er mal eine richtig schöne Party gegeben, weil das eine super Zeit war dieses halbe Jahr im Tempodrom. Und da hat jemand Akteneinsicht begehrt, um sich anzugucken, wofür die 25.000 Euro verbraten wurden für diese Feier. Da sind nämlich 25.000 Euro ausgegeben worden. Und aus persönlicher Quelle weiß ich, dass ich der Mitarbeiter, der die Akte herausgegeben hat, darüber gefreut hat, dass die Information beantragt wurde. Und dass es ihm äußerst unangenehm war, dass er noch eine kleine Gebühr, ich glaube es waren 11 Euro, dafür genommen hat. Denn natürlich war das total pervers, da 25.000 Euro zu verbraten.
Vielleicht seid genau ihr Behördenmitarbeiter und seid der Meinung, dass bestimmte Informationen einfach mal nachgefragt werden sollten. Und ihr könnt sie nicht nachfragen.
Wir freuen uns an anonyme Tipps.
Genau, auch dann seid ihr eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Wir sichern euch anonymität zu. Also ihr könnt hier auch irgendwelche Fantasienamen nehmen. Nur nicht tick, tick und tick, weil das sind ja die Neffen von Donald Duck. Chaosradio 109, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes Thema der Sendung. Im Studio Frank Rosengardt und Christoph... Ich will immer Buch sagen, aber du heißt Bruch, das ist mir sehr unangenehm. Ah, kaputt, Bruch, jetzt hab ich's auch. Unter euch am Telefon, 0331 77 97 1 0. Fragen, Anmerkungen zum Informationsfreiheitsgesetz? Vielleicht wollt ihr der einen oder anderen Information die Freiheit geben und vielleicht seid ihr ja auch Behördenmitarbeiter und möchtet gerne das Radio dazu benutzen, dem Bürger dazu aufzufordern, bestimmte Informationen nachzufragen, die quasi danach schreien, befreit zu werden. Nur ihr könnt es eben nicht, weil ihr... Wie heißt denn das eigentlich, wenn ein Beamter nicht... Schweigegelübde... Weil ihr einen Schweigegelübde abgelegt habt und den Vertrag mit einem Tropfenglut unterzeichnen musstet. Guten Abend Richie.
Mir funktioniert die Sache mit der Anfrage auch vor der Stadtverordnetenversammlung, also weil gesagt wurde, das muss nicht schriftlich gemacht werden. Da ist ja dann so manchmal meistens Bürgerfragestunde. Also kann ich mich da vorne hinstellen und meine Herren vom Amt in meinem Ort im Prinzip eine Frage stellen nach auch bestimmten Veräußerungen von Grundstücken oder bestimmten Baumaßnahmen oder zum Beispiel wurde ja auch ein Schwielosee bei uns in Färch, das ist eigentlich ein Naturschutzgebiet so mehr oder weniger. Da wurde auch eben mal genehmigt eine Wasserlandebahn für Flugzeuge, weil ja da jetzt zu die Haute Boulée im Prinzip ein Hotel gebaut wurde und Grundstücke im Prinzip hergerichtet wurden. Und das würde mich da schon mal interessieren, ob das alles mit den rechten Dingen zugegangen ist.
Jungs, wann habt ihr das letzte Mal das Wort Haute Boulée gehört? Das ist super Richie, echt auch schön. Ich muss das unbedingt in meinen aktiven Sprachschatz zurückführen.
Also die Frage ist natürlich legitim und auch wichtig und sie kann auch gestellt werden, aber natürlich nicht, wenn die Bürgerschaft tagt, dann haben die die Herrschaft über ihr Tagungsgebäude und über ihre Fragestunde. Aber du kannst natürlich zu dem Bauamt gehen oder der Naturschutzbehörde. Da hast du auch insofern sehr gute Karten, weil du dich nicht nur auf das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, sondern auch auf das Umweltinformationsgesetz stützen kannst. Das ist nochmal ein etwas weiterreichendes Gesetz. Das ist auch gebührenmäßig eventuell sogar etwas günstiger. Also die Informationen müsstest du kriegen. Also hättest du eigentlich ziemlich gute Karten.
Ja, na ist klar, denn wie gesagt, weil wir ja bisher eigentlich nur darüber gesprochen haben, über so größere Behörden und so und das ist ja jetzt im kleinen Rahmen, das spielt aber keine Rolle denn.
Nein, das spielt keine Rolle und in diesem speziellen Fall kommt es auch überhaupt nicht darauf an, ob du in einem der Bundesländer wohnst mit Informationsfreiheitsgesetzen, denn wahrscheinlich ist die für dich wichtige Rechtsgrundlage das Umweltinformationsgesetz und das die Umweltinformationsgesetz sind, haben wir in jedem Bundesland.
Wäre das im Prinzip auch angenommen. Die machen eine Beschuldigung von Straßen, nicht so wie ich mir das vorstelle. Also das müssten sie mir im Prinzip auch begründen, ja.
Mit anderen Worten, immer wenn du kommst, ist die Ampel nicht auf grün.
Ne, ne, ne, das geht um nochmal anders. Also das ist schöner am Stadtpark lang und so. Da wurde im Prinzip von 20 auf 30 erhöht und für Lkw frei heben. Und ja, das ist natürlich nicht ganz nachvollziehbar.
Aber ich finde das genau richtig.
Und solche Fragen, die müssen wir mir hochbeantworten. Also schriftlich darlegen oder auch nur mündlich.
Hab ich das gerade richtig verstanden? Ich kann da hingehen und sagen, und jetzt erklärt ihr mir, warum hier auf einmal die Lkws mit 50 durchdonnern dürfen.
Zunächst mal das Akteneinsichtsrecht. Auch als Umweltinformationsgesetz oder als Informationsfreiheitsgesetz gibt mir das Recht, Einsicht in Akten zu nehmen oder Kopien zu bekommen. Natürlich muss man gucken, inwieweit da noch eine Beratungspflicht mit einhergeht. Also angenommen, da ist jetzt ein Schild aufgestellt worden und es gibt von mir aus einen Gutachten, was ein normaler Mensch nicht verstehen kann, dann denke ich, ist die Verwaltung auch durchaus dazu angehalten, einem dieses Gutachten zu erklären. Aber du hast auf jeden Fall das Recht erfahren, wieso diese Schilder aufgestellt worden sind. Und das muss ja auch vorher begründet werden. Also das müsste ganz problemlos und schnell klappen.
Ich wollte eigentlich schon immer mal wissen, warum da jetzt ein komisches Heiteverbotschild bei mir vom Haus steht.
Ich wüsste mal gerne, es gibt eine Kreuzung, die mich immer völlig krank macht. Und zwar ist das die Kreuzung Mehringdamm-Gneisenau-Straße. Mehringdamm-Gneisenau-Straße in Kreuzberg. Da haben sie ewig um drei Tage an dieser Kreuzung Asphaltarbeiten durchgeführt. Und wenn du damit 30 drüber fährst, hast du das Gefühl, zerreißt dir den Wagen. Obwohl, also diese Kreuzung, also die ist jetzt, das ist jetzt die Berliner Definition von intakt. Da kann man im Grunde nicht nochmal drüber fahren. Vielleicht lässt sich das ja auch noch irgendwie nachfragen. Wir erziehen hier unsere Hörer zum Querulantentum. Wenn auch ihr Querulanten sein wollt, ruft an, spielt mit 0331 77 97 110. Wir begrüßen Bach.
Und zwar, ich hab ne Frage. Vor kurzem hat hier die EU die Data Retention angenommen.
Datenvorratsspeicherung, Verbindungsdatenvorratsspeicherung, ne?
Und zwar, bald ist die ja in Deutschland dann auch eingeführt. Gilt dann das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz auch dafür? Kann ich ankommen und nachfragen nach irgendwelchen Verbindungsdaten? Zum Beispiel auch unter anderem von mir.
Ich hab mein Telefonbuch vergessen können.
Nee, das geht nicht. Diese Data Retention Vorschrift, die besagt ja zunächst einmal nur, dass die Unternehmen, bei denen diese Daten anfallen, diese Daten speichern müssen über einen bestimmten Zeitraum. Und dass dann ganz wenige, nämlich die Sicherheitsbehörden, wer genau muss ja noch festgelegt werden, darauf Zugriff haben. Die Daten liegen also nicht beim Amt, die Daten liegen bei den Privaten und da gilt ja bei uns das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz nicht.
Aber im Grunde, für die Polizei gilt ja, dass ich dann abgeschlossene Fälle anschauen kann. Das ist ja auch der Sicherheitsbereich.
Ja, das muss man dann angucken. Ich hatte ja eben schon gesagt, dazu kenne ich mich jetzt zu wenig aus, wie da diese Akten auch genau aussehen. Aber wenn eine Ermittlung abgeschlossen ist, dann besteht grundsätzlich die Möglichkeit, Einsicht in diese Akte zu beantragen. Inwieweit diese Einsicht gewährt werden kann, muss im Einzelfall geprüft werden.
Also immer erstmal Fragen gehen.
Das hilft.
Chaosradio 109, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, ist unser Thema.
Ich habe eine Detailfrage zu den Kosten. Und zwar, es gibt ja so eine Liste, das ist ein bisschen gemein, das ist ein PDF, das man nicht ausdrucken kann. Es ist hoffentlich kein Vorgeschmack auf das, was uns da noch blüht an Informationen. Den kriegen wir zwar zugeschickt, aber können sie nicht ausdrucken. Ja, aber das ist ja kein Weg, das kann man nicht machen. Anyway, es gibt eine Gebührenordnung für das Bundesinformationsfreiheitsgesetz. Und da sind mehrere Posten aufgeführt. Mich würde interessieren, wenn es jetzt eine Information gibt, wie zum Beispiel auch die Sachen mit dem Epas. Das wissen wir, das sind alles elektronische Dokumente. Das heißt, die sind mit einem Klick per E-Mail verschickt. Muss ich dann da trotzdem eigentlich irgendwas bezahlen? Weil das sind ja eigentlich Auslagen für Kopien, Versandkosten und so was. Wie sieht das da aus?
Also ich gehe davon aus, wenn ich mich an ein Amt wende und sage, ich hätte gern ein bestimmtes Gutachten. Und dieses Gutachten liegt in elektronischer Form, beispielsweise als PDF-Datei vor und kann einfach so per Mail verschickt werden, dann sehe ich eigentlich keinen Grund dafür, dafür irgendwelche Gebühren zu erheben.
Und es gibt, soweit ich die Gebührenordnung verstanden habe, oder auch die Berichterstattung darüber, gibt es die Möglichkeit, quasi auch aufwände, besondere Aufwände zu verlangen von der Behörde. Was muss ich mir darunter vorstellen, wenn jetzt jemand sozusagen die fünf Minuten, die es dauert, das Dokument rauszusuchen, oder das muss jetzt jemand losgehen, dieses Dokument suchen, oder ist es eher für kompliziertere Fälle gedacht, wenn zum Beispiel Stellen geschwärzt werden müssen oder Akkenteile unkenntlich gemacht werden oder entfernt werden?
Also bei der Gebührenordnung wird unterschieden zwischen den eigentlichen Gebühren und den sogenannten Auslagen. Die Gebühren sind, wenn man so will, für die Arbeit, die im Amt entsteht, um die Informationen herauszusuchen beispielsweise. Die Auslagen sind die Kosten, die entstehen, zum Beispiel durch Vervielfältigung. Also angenommen, ich will bestimmte elektronische Informationen haben und die sollen auf eine CD gebrannt werden, die mir zugeschickt wird, dann wären die Auslagen, die Kosten für die CD und von mir aus auch das Porto oder sowas in der Art. Und da wird man nochmal gucken müssen in der Praxis, wo sich die Gebühren da genau einpendeln und was da unter Umständen genommen wird. Also ich habe hier diese Gebührenordnung hier vorliegen, die wollen beispielsweise für eine Farbkopie, wie war das genau, für eine Farbkopie wollten die glaube ich 5 Euro haben oder wie war das? Eine Fotokopie Format DIN-A3 kostet 2, 56 Euro.
Vielleicht sollte denen mal ein Copyshop ein gutes Angebot machen.
Das erschien mir auch etwas unverhältnismäßig. Aber das wird wahrscheinlich nochmal ausgetestet werden. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass in den Regelfall die Ämter gutwillig sind und die ihren Spielraum hoffentlich eher nach unten als nach oben nutzen.
Fragen, Anmerkungen zum Informationsfreiheitsgesetz 0331 70 97 110. Hier in Chaosradio 109 auf Fritz. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist das Thema heute Abend. Möglicherweise wisst ihr eine Information, der ihr gerne zur Freiheit verhelfen würdet. Dann seid ihr eingeladen uns das zu erzählen und natürlich allen anderen. Die Radio hören auch unter 0331 70 97 110. Möglicherweise habt ihr auch eine Frage zum Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Möglicherweise kann nämlich der Christoph diese Frage beantworten. Viel zu viele möglicherweise ist, die ich jetzt hier in dieser Stelle hatte. Kann Christoph die Frage beantworten. Christoph kommt nämlich von der humanistischen Union, der ältesten Bürgerrechtsbewegung. Bürgerrechtsbewegung? Organisation. Bürgerrechtsorganisation. Nicht Regierungsorganisation für Bürgerrechtsbewegungen.
Nicht möglicherweise, sondern ganz bestimmt könnt ihr uns eine Mail schreiben. Wenn ihr nicht anrufen wollt, könnt ihr uns eine Mail schicken an chaosradio.ccc.de oder geht auf unsere Webseite chaosradio.ccc.de ohne www. Da gibt es auch die Möglichkeit den Chaosradio-Ticker zu subscriben, wie man auf Neudeutsch sagt, also euch dafür anzumelden. Das ist immer dann gut, wenn ihr vergesst, dass wieder Chaosradio ist. Da erinnern wir euch immer ein, zwei Tage vorher. Und da schicken wir noch irgendwelche aktuellen Sachen rum. Ich möchte hinweisen auf den Podcast, den wir haben. Das ist also ein Audiofeed, wo es die ganzen Mitschnitte gibt, unter anderem auch den Chaosradio Express, den es also zusätzlich gibt zum Chaosradio. Das ist also ein kleines Add-on, wo wir also auch bei den Themen mal mehr in die Tiefe gehen können. Und da gibt es ja keine Anrufer, sondern da sitzt Tim in der Regel mit einem Studio Gast und unterhält sich dann einfach ganz ganz locker mal über das ein oder andere Thema. Es gibt wie man so ein Podcast macht, wenn ihr so ein Podcast mal selber machen wollt, dann gibt es morgen eine Veranstaltung in Berlin im New Thinking in der Tucholskystraße. Da gibt es also einen kleinen Einführungsvortrag, wie man selber Podcasts machen kann. Und ich möchte noch hinweisen auf die Net Label Party im RAW Tempel in Friedrichshain am Samstag. Da wird nämlich nur freie Musik gespielt. Das ist also eine Party, wo nur Musik von Netzmusik gespielt wird.
Und wenn ihr selber podcasten wollt, empfehle ich euch die Lektüre des Buches Schreiben fürs Hören. Es ist nämlich bisweilen wirklich unerträglich, was da so auf meine Festplatte gefallen kommt.
Aber hallo.
Es ist wirklich ganz jenseits von Gut und Böse. Also nur weil man eine gute Stimme hat, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das einen befähigt, auch Sachverhalte einigermaßen kohärent darzulegen. Schreiben fürs Hören, ein Buch für alle, die gerne Podcasts machen würden, auch ein Buch, das unser eins Radiomensch mit in die Wiege gelegt bekommt, sozusagen. Das ist in der Tat ein sehr gutes Buch. 0331 77 91 ins 0 wiederum ist die Nummer der Fritz-Hortlein und ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen, euch zu verhalten zum Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, so wie der Florian sich jetzt verhalten wird. Hallo Florian.
Meine Frage ist die, und zwar, wenn ich jetzt eine Anfrage an der Behörde stelle. Und die nennen mir die Kosten. Haben sie da die Arbeit eigentlich schon gemacht? Oder ist es dann so, dass die abschätzen, okay, da müssen wir das und das und das machen und das wird so und so viel kosten?
Das liegt zunächst mal an der Behörde. Entscheidend ist allerdings, dass die Behörde nicht, wenn sie die Arbeit denn schon gemacht haben sollte und die Information nicht in Anspruch genommen wird, dann kann sie auch keine Rechnung stellen. Das ist ganz wichtig.
Und wie ist das jetzt, wenn ich, also wenn die mir sagen, das kostet meinetwegen 50 Euro jetzt die Information, die ich haben möchte. Und ich frag dann ja, warum kostet das so viel? Und die sagen, na ja, da mussten wir zehn Farbkopien machen, das kostet 50 Euro. Kann ich dann sagen, ich hätte das schon gerne, aber Farbkopie kostet auch keine 5 Euro, dass ich mich da irgendwie wehe und sag, ja, billiger würde ich es nehmen.
Das ist möglich und ich glaube in vielen Fällen auch erfolgreich. Wie immer empfehle ich den Gang zum Informationsfreiheitsbeauftragten, die in der Regel sich der Sache auch nochmal annehmen. Und ich kenne eine ganze Reihe von Beispielen, in denen die Höhe der Gebühren noch ganz erheblich gedrückt werden konnte.
0331 77 97 110.
Wir haben auf der Mitmachseite bei Wikipedia, die ist verlinkt von unserer Chaosradio-Homepage, da ist eine Frage nach der Authentifizierung. Das heißt also, wie prüfen die Behörden nach, ob ich wirklich derjenige bin, der ich behaupte zu sein?
Biometrischen Pass?
Das heißt also, ich schreibe da irgendwie hin und sage, ich hätte jetzt gerne die Informationen und möglicherweise, also wir haben ja schon gehört, dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, personenbezogene Daten, dass die geschwärzt werden zum Beispiel. Das wäre jetzt sinnlos, wenn meine eigenen Daten auch geschwärzt werden. Wenn ich jetzt aber vorgebe, jemand anders zu sein, könnte ich damit ja möglicherweise an fremde Daten kommen auch. Oder an Daten, die mir so nicht zugänglich wären.
Also das ist schon sehr um die Ecke gedacht. Also dieser Fall ist mir noch nicht bekannt, dass es das schon einmal gegeben hätte. Also naheliegend ist ja vielleicht, dass du sagst, ich bin jemand anderes, also du gibst dich für jemand anderen aus und beantragst dann auf Grundlage der informationellen Selbstbestimmung sozusagen in deine eigene Akte, obwohl es gar nicht deine eigene Akte ist. In solchen Fällen muss natürlich geprüft werden, dass die Person, die den Antrag stellt, tatsächlich die Person ist. Aber mir ist auch noch nicht bekannt geworden, dass es da schon mal Probleme gab.
Da gab es mal so einen Film mit Sandra Bullock.
In Hollywood soll ja viel möglich sein.
Da geht alles, Amerika, da geht alles. Guten Abend, Danilo.
Mein Anliegen ist folgendes. Und zwar wurde ich am Montagabend hier in Berlin. Also ich hatte mir, es ist total unverständlich, ich hatte mir für Fahrradfahrer hier so eine reflektierende Streifen an die Beine gemacht und wurde trotzdem fast umgefahren. Also das Auto ist 50 Zentimeter von mir zum Stehen gekommen an dieser Kreuzung. Und ich habe natürlich eine Anzeige bei der Polizei gemacht. Und mich würde mal interessieren, aus Datenschutzgrund, können Sie mir den Halter des Fahrzeugs nicht nennen, wie das dann weitergeht jetzt?
Das ist aber auch kein Fall fürs Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
Das ist kein Fall fürs Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, aber trotzdem insofern natürlich eine wichtige Frage, weil diese Datenschutzfrage einfach sehr zentral ist. Natürlich hat man einen Anspruch darauf informiert zu werden, wie eine Anzeige verfolgt wird. Das wird auch dokumentiert. Ich habe selber das Problem gehabt, ich hatte Stress mit einem Nachbarn bei uns im Hause, der immer sehr laut Musik gemacht hat. Und den musste ich auch x-mal anzeigen, bis das irgendwann mal besser wurde. Man macht dann eine Anzeige und hat dann auch hinterher die Möglichkeit, einen Beleg darüber zu bekommen. Aber natürlich kann man nicht ohne Weiteres den Namen von so jemandem bekommen. Weil es könnte ja auch sein, dass du versuchst, das Recht in eigene Hände zu nehmen. Das soll natürlich nicht gemacht werden. Und dann? Du sagst ja sozusagen, ich sag jetzt mal, gefällige Körperverletzung. Oder versuchte Körperverletzung. Oder fahrlässiges.
Geht auch in die Richtung.
Genau. Und das heißt, jetzt muss sich ja die Staatsanwaltschaft eine Meinung bilden, ob das vorgelegen hat oder nicht. Und dann schilderst du den Fall aus deiner Sicht und die schreiben die Person an. Und der sagt, nee, nee, das war ganz anders. Ich hab eigentlich schon fast geparkt. Und da ist der mit dem Fahrrad vor mich gesprungen. Und dann muss die Staatsanwaltschaft feststellen, ob sie da ein Verfahren eröffnen will oder nicht. Und wenn die das dann nicht machen wollen, dann musst du unter Umständen Beschwerde dagegen einlegen. Aber das ist zunächst mal nicht unbedingt ein Problem, auf die Darstellung der Gegenseite zugreifen zu können. Sondern die müssen wir ja gegenüber glaubhaft machen, wieso sie so ein Verfahren aufmachen oder nicht.
Ist aber letztendlich auch keine Frage oder kein Problem jetzt. Nee, so gar nicht.
Danilo, viel Erfolg trotzdem bei deinem Fall.
Ich danke euch und wünschen euch alles Gute.
Eine interessante Frage haben wir auch noch über die Mitmachseite im Wikipedia bekommen. Muss ich eigentlich deutscher Staatsbürger sein, um so eine Anfrage zu machen?
Das ist eine sehr, sehr spannende Frage. Die gute Nachricht muss ich nicht. Das ist ein Recht, das jede Person hat. Man muss noch nicht mal Bürger sein, also auch juristische Personen können die Anfrage stellen. Das ist aber gar nicht unbedingt selbstverständlich. Derzeit wird die Einführung eines Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes auch in Hamburg diskutiert. Da soll es ein Privileg der Landeskinder sein. Ob sich das durchhalten lässt, weiß ich nicht, denn man kann ja auch ganz leicht einen Strom anfinden.
Ihr hat Chaosradio 109, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist das Thema der Sendung. Und nach den Nachrichten machen wir weiter möglicherweise mit euren Fragen unter 033 177 97 110.
Die folgenden Songs haben etwas gemeinsam. Die alle wurden aufgenommen und produziert in den Berliner Hansa Studios. Und die könnt ihr euch jetzt angucken. Jetzt auch als Special die Fritz Music Tour durch die legendären Hansa-Studios. Fritz Music Tours Berlin.
Mehr Infos fritz.de und im Radio.
Bei der ersten palästinensischen Parlamentswahl seit zehn Jahren zeichnet sich ein knapper Sieg der regierenden Fatah ab. Die ersten Hochrechnungen nach den ersten Hochrechnungen verliert die Partei von Palästinenser Präsident Abbas die absolute Mehrheit. Trotzdem kann sie aber voraussichtlich ohne die radikale islamische Hamas regieren. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel will den Bürokratieabbau voranbringen. In ihrer Eröffnungsrede auf dem Weltwirtschaftsforum im schweizerischen Davos sagte sie, die Vereinfachung der Verwaltung werde ein Hauptthema der deutschen EU-Präsidentschaft 2007 sein. In der BND-Irak-Affäre wird es vorerst keinen parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss geben. FDP und Linkspartei haben es nicht geschafft, einen entsprechenden Gruppenantrag durchzubringen. Beide Parteien erreichten nur 125 Stimmen, 154 wären aber nötig gewesen. Die Menschenrechtsorganisation Amnesty International hat erstmals eine detaillierte Liste von insgesamt 48 CIA-Flügen über Deutschland vorgelegt. Die Generalsekretärin der deutschen Sektion Leochbieler forderte zu den Flügen und der Folter von Gefangenen einen Untersuchungsausschuss. Die Bundesregierung habe die Pflicht, die Öffentlichkeit zu informieren. Zum Sport. Im Viertelfinale des DFB-Pokals gab es am Abend folgende Ergebnisse. Aminir Bielefeld, Kickers Offenbach 4 zu 3 im EFMETA-Schießen, 1860 Müncheneintracht Frankfurt 1 zu 3 und St. Pauli Werder Bremen 3 zu 1. Damit sind Bayern München, Bielefeld, Frankfurt und St. Pauli im Halbfinale. Die Basketballer von Alba Berlin haben mit ihrem 15. Sieg im 17. Spiel ihre Spitzenposition in der Bundesliga verteidigt. Sie besiegten Energie Braunschweig mit 98 zu 79. In dieser Nacht wechseln wirkig die Temperaturen sinken auf minus 5 bis minus 10 Grad und am Tag wird es wieder heiter, wolkig, meist trocken, deutlich wärmer, minus 5 bis minus 2 Grad. Da ist irgendwas falsch gedrückt, macht nichts, ich hab hier eine Verkehrsmeldung. Die ich dann so lese, die ist Autobahn 115, Dreigfunkturm Richtung Nutetal zwischen kleinen Machne und dem Parkplatz mit WC am Stern. Unfall, zwei Fahrstreifen auf der 115 sind blockiert, der Stau reicht bereits bis nach Berlin zurück.
Entschuldigung, Parkplatz mit WC?
Der heißt offiziell so.
Vielen Dank Matthias Gerkhoff, Fritz wünscht gute Fahrt um 0 Uhr 32.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz in Spremberg.
Chaosradio 109 mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Falls ihr da Fragen habt, Anmerkungen habt, zu erzählen wollt, welche Informationen ihr gerne die Freiheit geben wollen würdet, seid ihr eingeladen anzurufen. Noch bis kurz vor eins unter 0331 70 97 110. Chaosradio 109, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Das Bundesinformationsfreiheitsgesetz ist unser Thema. In vier Bundesländern gibt es das schon. Berlin, Brandenburg, Nordrhein-Westfalen und Schleswig-Holstein, wenn ich richtig aufgepasst habe.
Hab ich? Genau.
Hab ich, habe ich. Bestätigt habe ich gerade Christoph Bruch von der humanistischen Union. Außerdem im Studio von Rosengardt, vom CCC. Die Knöpfe drückt Holger Klein.
Ja, eigentlich ist es ja schon fast so ein bisschen so ein Fazit zu machen. Eine ganz interessante Frage noch, die wir aber glaube ich hier gar nicht so klären können ist, es gibt von der Bundesprüfstelle für jugendgefährdende Schriften, die also Medien auf den Index setzen. Dieser Index bleibt aber geheim, um nicht noch mehr Werbung für diese Sachen zu machen. Und da kam jetzt auch in der Wikipedia Mitmachseite die Frage, ob man die denn auch per IFG, per Informationsfreiheitsgesetz bekommen könnte. Welches Recht denn da höher wiegt das Recht auf Information, also das Recht der Öffentlichkeit, diese Liste zu kennen oder eben das Recht oder der Wunsch diese Liste geheim zu halten, um eben noch mehr Öffentlichkeit für diese eigentlich indizierten Seiten zu bekommen?
Also ich habe selber davon gehört und überlegt, ob ich persönlich einen Antrag stellen soll, diese Information zu erhalten. Denn das muss ja auch nachprüfbar sein, wer da indiziert wird. Also es geht ja nicht nur darum, dass...
Das ist ja schließlich nicht die kirchliche Inquisition oder was?
Genau, aber die Spezies. Ich kann da gar keine verbindliche rechtliche Auskunft drüber geben. Mein Rechtsgefühl sagt mir, natürlich muss diese Information zugänglich sein. Mein Rechtsgefühl vor allen Dingen als Vertreter der humanistischen Union. Also muss ich doch das Bürgerrecht haben, nachprüfen zu können, was mir da vorenthalten werden soll. Das muss auf jeden Fall begründungsfähig sein und mir erscheint die Argumentation, das geheim zu halten, weil man sonst Werbung für diese Seiten mache, sehr fadenscheinig.
Jetzt ist ja diese Möglichkeit, die wir als Bürger jetzt in den Händen haben, ja eine ganz schöne Sache. Aber das Endziel oder also ich stelle mir das eigentlich vor, unter gläserner Verwaltung oder Maschinenlesbare Regierung, das ist ein Begriff, der im CCC-Umfeld auch seit 20 Jahren geprägt wurde, Maschinenlesbare Regierung. Das heißt, die Regierung, die Behörden stellen eigentlich alles, was sie haben, online. Im Prinzip spricht er ja nichts gegen. Die meisten Sachen werden mittlerweile elektronisch gemacht, also okay, außer auf den paar Amtsstuben, die haben halt noch eine gute alte Schreibmaschine, da kann ich es verstehen. Aber das ist ja ein Prozess, der jetzt in ein paar Jahren kommt. Wird es denn auch dazu führen, dass die Behörden wirklich offener werden? Wird dann umdenken, einsetzen, was ja eigentlich das Gesetz auch bewirken soll? Also es geht ja gar nicht darum, den Nörglern, Anführungszeichen unter den Bürgern irgendwie eine Möglichkeit an die Hand zu geben, die Behörden noch mehr zu beschäftigen. Das soll ja insgesamt umdenken passieren in den Behörden. Das heißt, die Behörden sollen einfach insgesamt transparenter, offener arbeiten. Glaubst du denn, dass das Gesetz dazu geeignet ist, dass da was passieren wird?
Da bin ich sehr zuversichtlich. Nicht nur, weil die Behörden ihre Mentalität verändern werden, das ist das eine, was ich glaube, dann es wird einfach auch zu mehr Effizienz führen. Und wenn wir eine Umstellung haben auf Workflow-Systemen, was ja bis jetzt noch nicht da ist, dann wird es möglich sein, in zentralen Datenbanken die einzelnen Dokumente, die dort liegen, mit einem, sagen wir, vermerkt zu versehen, ob sie über eine externe Schnittstelle abgerufen werden können oder nicht. Auf EU-Eben ist das ja jetzt im Teil schon verwirklicht. Da gibt es schon diese Register und dann kann man eben bestimmte Dokumente einziehen und nicht. Es gibt noch ein technisches Problem. Und zwar können ja in einer Akte oder in einem elektronischen Dokument, also in einer Datei, Informationen sein, die können rausgehen und Informationen sein, die können nicht rausgehen. Das heißt, wenn diese Akte, wenn diese Datei angelegt wird, muss entweder die Person, die die Datei anlegt, diese entsprechenden sensiblen Stellen kennzeichnen oder es muss irgendein schlauer Algorithmus erfunden werden, der diese Stellen relativ treffsicher heraussucht, damit man das einfach so freischalten kann. Und ich habe mich da auch schon mal mit Vertretern von Firmen unterhalten, die sowas anbieten und die haben mir gesagt, also automatisch funktioniert das bis jetzt noch nicht. Und dann ist natürlich klar, wenn jemand einen ganz normalen Datei anlegt, also einen längeren Text in Word schreibt und ich will von dem verlangen, dass der sich überlegt, was da alles für sensible Informationen drin schickt und die muss er dann direkt irgendwie kennzeichnen, das wäre sehr, sehr viel Arbeit und das für jedes Dokument zu verlangen, damit es potenziell direkt abgerufen werden kann, ist wahrscheinlich beim momentanen Stand der Technik übertrieben.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ich, also das ist dann schon noch ein bisschen ein komplexeres Problem, aber wenn ich quasi die Personen, also sozusagen die Entitäten und Firmen Namen extra aufführe und dann quasi im Dokument auch schon pseudonymisiert habe, dass ich die sozusagen von vornherein schon trenne die Informationen mit dem Ziel, dass ich das Ding dann anonymisiert rausgeben kann. Das wäre ein Weg möglicher.
Ja, das wird ja auch angestrebt, aber man muss eben sehen, es gibt sicher Kontext, in denen das gut zu machen ist und andere Zusammenhängen, in denen das schwieriger ist.
0331 70 97 11 0 ist die Nummer der Fritz-Hotline. Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen, Anmerkungen loszuwerden zum Informationsfreiheitsgesetz oder zu erzählen, welchen Informationen ihr die Freiheit wünschen würdet. Der Florian Spahnberg ist noch mal dran.
Ja hallo, ich hab Informationen zur BPJM. Zu was?
Bundesprüfstelle für jugendgefährte Medien.
Und zwar war ja die Frage, wie man an diese Liste der indizierten und beschlagnahmten Medien kommen kann. Und das ist auch ohne Informationsfreiheitsgesetz möglich. Und zwar schon seit längerem, da gibt es eine Publikation von dieser Stelle, die sich BPJM aktuell nennt. Und an die kommt man entweder dran, indem man die abonniert, was natürlich umständlich ist. Oder man kann in öffentlichen Bibliotheken oder beim Jugendamt oder auch bei der Polizei kann man da reinschauen und da ist eine vollständige Liste drin.
Ah ja, das ist ja sehr interessante, tolle Information.
Was wir auch noch nicht geklärt haben, ist... Oh, blabla. Wovereits Terminkalender. Das haben wir noch gar nicht zu Ende geklärt. Also die Frage lautete und ihr seid immer noch eingeladen, die zu beantworten unter 0331 77 97 170. Sollte der dienstliche Terminkalender von Wovereit vom regierenden Bürgermeister Berlins veröffentlicht werden oder nicht? Wie sieht es da aus? Also woher kommt überhaupt diese Frage?
Ich kann ja mal der verunsicherten Bürgerschaft von Berlin und Brandenburg etwas Mut machen. Der Terminkalender des amerikanischen Präsidenten ist zugänglich. Und zwar ist er aus folgendem Grund unter anderem eingesehen worden, als schon der gute Herr Bush noch nicht Präsident der USA war, sondern Kandidat war, ist überprüft worden, wie viel er gearbeitet hat als Governor, als als Regierungschef von Texas. Und da hat man über einen längeren Zeitraum, ich weiß nicht, ob ein Jahr oder wie viel auch immer, sich die gesamten Daten des Terminkalenders geben lassen. Sie sind auch rausgegeben worden und man konnte feststellen, Herr Bush ist morgens so gegen 9 Uhr ins Büro gekommen, hat ungefähr zwei Stunden Mittagspause gemacht, denn er geht gerne joggen und so gegen 5 Uhr hat er seinen letzten Termin angesetzt und dann den Feierabend eingeläutet. Das war überhaupt kein Problem, das festzustellen. Und ich erwähne auch noch einen anderen Fall, der geht jetzt weg von dem Terminkalender, der ist aber auch sehr spannend. Auch der E-Mail-Verkehr im Weißen Haus ist für das Informationsfeuersgesetz des Amerikanischen zugänglich. Die Iran-Contra-Affäre ist genau dadurch so richtig ins Rollen gekommen, denn da hat ein Journalist Einsicht in das E-Mail-System verlangt und konnte damit E-Mails auswendig machen von Olli North, in dem dokumentiert wurde, wie Geschäfte gemacht wurden mit Drogendeals, um die Contras in Nicaragua zu finanzieren.
Das wollen die doch natürlich verhindern. Also gerade solche Geschäfte oder solche Mails sollen doch nicht an die Öffentlichkeit.
Was machen die denn da? Jetzt komme ich nämlich zu einer ganz kitzlichen Angelegenheit. Wenn man als Lobbyist sich für ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz einsetzt, dann bekommt man manchmal auch zu hören, dass zu viel Transparenz dazu führen würde, dass die Aktenführer auch nicht mehr gut laufen würde. Dass nämlich dann die kitzlichen Informationen nicht mehr in die Akten geschrieben würden. Und das Problem ist natürlich vorhanden.
Wo wären sie dann hingeschrieben? Weil sie müssen ja aufgeschrieben werden.
Da kommt dann so komische, bizarre Begründung wie in Brandenburg, da ist ja ja keine Akte da, sondern da sind nur Unterlagen abgeheftet worden.
Darf man dafür eigentlich die Behördermitarbeiterohr feigen?
Also dann wäre ich ja mal vorsichtig, bevor ich mir mal die... Nicht, okay.
Hätte ja sein können.
Wenn man die Datei... Gib das her! Also ich kann nur sagen, der frühere Präsident... Wie heißt der gute Blonde, dessen Frau jetzt? Clinton, genau. Der gute Herr Clinton. Der hat gesagt, er hat keine E-Mails geschickt, als er Präsident war, um genau diese Problematik aus dem Weg zu gehen. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Sache. Nein, aber das muss man schon ganz ernsthaft betrachten. Natürlich wird es als Argument vorgebracht, dass innerhalb dieser abgeschlossenen Raumschiffsverwaltung eine Öffentlichkeit, eine Offenheit herrschte, die jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr herrschen würde. Ich glaube allerdings, und das kann man auch durchaus belegen, wenn man in die skandinavischen Länder guckt, diese ganze Haltung zu dem Gesetz kann sich auch verändern. Also man kann da eine positive Haltung zu haben und kann auch stolz darauf sein, dass bestimmte Informationen zugänglich sind. Und ich bin davon überzeugt, dass 99 Prozent der Informationen ohnehin ohne Probleme herausgegeben werden können. Und wenn sich unsere Behördmitarbeiter erst daran gewöhnt haben, ist das überhaupt kein Problem mehr.
Habt ihr da irgendwelche Erkenntnisse darüber, was die Ängste oder Sorgen der Behördmitarbeiter beim Einzelnen sind? Also klar, diffuse, da könnte Missbrauch sein oder sowas. Haben die einfach nur Angst vor Veränderungen?
Ich denke, wir haben einfach ganz klar Angst davor, dass man merkt, dass sie vielleicht nicht effektiv oder nicht richtig arbeiten.
Ich kann das nachvollziehen, aber ich finde, das ist so ein bisschen Wohlfeil. Das ist das, was man ohnehin den Behörden immer unterstellt.
Ich glaube, ein Teil des Problems ist, dass in Entscheidungsprozessen offen diskutiert wird, über bestimmte Dinge, in einer offenen Weise, die man eben in der Öffentlichkeit, würde man mit Argumenten, die in der Öffentlichkeit nicht in dieser Härte unter Umständen vorgestellt würden. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Gewöhnungsprozess für die Öffentlichkeit. Also wenn wir mehr Transparenz haben möchten, dann müssen wir auch unter Umständen damit rechnen, unsere Behörden diese Entscheidungsprozesse etwas anders kennenzulernen, als es bisher der Fall war.
Wobei die Entscheidungsprozesse ja auch nicht durchs IFG abgedeckt sind, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Das heißt also, irgendwelche Sachen, die noch in der Entwicklung sind oder die tatsächlich noch im Diskussionsstadium sind, müssen ja auch nicht rausgegeben werden.
Ja, das kommt natürlich darauf an. Also es gibt Bösezungen, die behaupten, dass Informationsfreiheitsgesetz mache nur Informationen zugänglich, wenn die Verwaltung nicht mehr handelt. Da ist auch vom Prinzip her etwas dran. Also es gibt das sogenannte Beratungsgeheimnis, was da geschützt wird. Allerdings auch wenn ein Verwaltungsakt abgeschlossen ist und danach Informationen zugänglich werden, sind ja immer noch die gleichen Personen dort tätig. Also das ist trotzdem noch sehr relevant, dass diese Informationen zugänglich sind.
Können ihr eigentlich auch Namen von Sachbearbeitern rausstreichen? Wer da zuständig ist für so eine Akte?
Das wäre aber doch absurd.
Das wurde glaube ich schon probiert, aber das ist nach meiner Meinung nicht okay. Nein, nein, das geht nicht. Also vielleicht auch in den Ausnahmeklauseln für den Datenschutz in den Informationsfreiheitsgesetzen steht auch immer deutlich drin, dass Namen zu den Sachbearbeitern oder zu Gutachtern, deren Titel, Telefonnummer und so weiter nicht durch die Datenschutzausnahme geschützt werden.
Ich bin gespannt, was ihr da mit uns zu sehen habt. Chaosradio 109 neigt sich dem Ende zu. Das Thema der heutigen Sendung war das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
Selbstverteidigung für Bürger nennen wir das auch. Und wir haben darüber gesprochen, dass es ein neues Gesetz gibt, was eigentlich gar kein neues ist, weil es in Berlin und Brandenburg schon seit ein paar Jahren gibt, nur es weiß niemand davon. Wir wollten die Sendung als Gelegenheit nehmen, euch das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz bekannt zu machen, euch einfach raten, euch bitten, nutzt dieses Gesetz, fordert Informationen an, die ihr immer schon mal haben wolltet. Geht zu den Behörden, fragt nach, bittet darum und veröffentlicht was daran auch, dass die anderen auch was haben. Wir wollen die Verwaltung nicht unnötig belasten. Wir wollen jede Anfrage nur einmal stellen möglichst. Und ja, es ist gar nicht so schlimm. Die Kosten werden sich hoffentlich auch an Grenzen halten. Wir haben gehört, wir brauchen also gar keinen förmlichen Antrag schreiben, sondern es reicht möglicherweise auch dahin zu gehen, einfach anzurufen, mal zu fragen. Die Behörden müssen auch Auskunft geben, welche Informationen es gibt. Das heißt, sie müssen auch behilflich sein, die richtigen Akten zu finden. In einem gewissen Rahmen. Was gibt es sonst noch wichtiges zu?
Also ich glaube, es ist wichtig am Ende sozusagen als Abschluss auch noch mal festzuhalten, dass das ein sogenannter Paradigmenwechsel ist. Also wir sind ja alle groß geworden mit dem Amtsgeheimnis vor Augen. Also auch die Leute, die in der Verwaltung arbeiten, die haben gelernt, jede Information innerhalb der Verwaltung ist erst mal vertraulich und nur im Ausnahmefällen kann sie herausgegeben werden. Und durch die Informationsfreiheitsgesetze wird dieses Prinzip gedreht. Jede Information ist zunächst mal öffentlich zugänglich und nur wenn bestimmte Ausnahmeklauseln greifen, darf die Information geheim gehalten werden. Und das ist eine uralte Forderung. Die ist ja 200 Jahre alt, diese Forderung.
Gibt es nachvollziehbar, wer die zum ersten Mal gestellt hat? Also berühmte Persönlichkeiten, die gesagt haben, ich muss weiter.
Naja, es gibt berühmte Persönlichkeiten aus der Aufklärung, die diese Forderung gestellt haben. Es gibt Zitate von Benjamin Franklin, von Madison. Die älteste Quelle, die ich persönlich gefunden habe, stammt aus dem 17. Jahrhundert aus Massachusetts. Da gibt es eine Vorschrift schon über Akten. Die älteste Gesetz kommt auch aus dem 18. Jahrhundert aus Schweden. Also es ist ein klassisches Kind der Aufklärung als Gegenreaktion auf den Absolutismus. Und man muss sich wirklich klar machen, dass über so lange Zeit in ganz vielen kleinen Schritten für mehr Transparenz im Staat gekämpft wurde. Und die Transparenz vom Staat hängt natürlich nicht nur an den Informationsfreiheitsgesetzen. Aber das ist eine ganz wesentliche Sache. Und deswegen bin ich stolz, dass wir jetzt ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in Deutschland haben auf Bundesebene. Ich freue mich, dass wir es in vielen Ländern haben. Ich bin sehr froh, dass die ehemalige Opposition aus der DDR es geschafft hat, in Brandenburg nicht nur ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, sondern vor allen Dingen, und das ist einmalig in Deutschland, in der Brandenburger Verfassung, Artikel 21, ein Recht der Bürger auf Zugang zu Informationen der Verwaltung zu verankern. Das ist ein echter Fortschritt gewesen. Auch wenn wir im Laufe dieser Abends noch eine ganze Reihe Defizite benannt haben.
Und jetzt kann niemand mehr sagen, die Politiker machen, was sie wollen. Zumindestens können wir ihnen jetzt auf die Finger schauen.
Chaosradio 109 ist zu Ende. Im Studio waren Frank Rosengardt, ccc.de und Christoph Bruch von der humanistischen Union, humanistische-union.de, wenn ihr da Informationen haben wollt. Informationen zum Informationsfreiheitsgesetz findet ihr natürlich auch auf der Seite des Chaos Computer Clubs unter ccc.de. Das nächste Chaos Radio gibt es am letzten Mittwoch im Februar. Was das für ein Datum ist, entzieht sich gerade mein Erkenntnis, denn mein ewiger Kalender ist gerade abwesend. Aber im Folgenden kann ich euch sagen, was es gibt, und zwar am 26. Januar, den wir mittlerweile haben, nämlich den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Das war's Chaos Radio. Mein Name ist Holger Klein. Ich danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Gute Nacht.